Was heißt das?
Alle durcheinander reden bitte.
Lass uns das permanent durcheinander geschreien und.
Versetzt euch doch mal in die Lage des Hörers.
Der Simons Cat ist ja meine Lieblings-Abar.
Unser User-Interface ist nicht mehr gut.
Mobile-Max kommt in verschiedene Moderatoren schräg entgegen.
Wir hätten ihn nicht ganz so viel.
Bitte fahren Sie auf die Seite Lanzera Abwunderung.
Halten Sie sich ruhig.
Das ist ein Vorkrass, das ist ein Dali-Gemälde geworden.
Wisst ihr was dran ist heute?
Test, Test, Test, Test.
Wir haben ja alle unsere Kresse dabei, um mal Herrn Lauer zu zitieren. Öfter mal die Kresse halten.
War schon ein bisschen mutig, oder?
Was?
Die letzte Sendung?
Nee, von dem Lauer. Ich musste echt jetzt lange überlegen, ob ich irgendwie was Symbolisches verpasst hab, oder ob ich das wirklich so mein, wie ich jetzt denke.
Aber die letzte Sendung war ein voller Erfolg, möchte ich mal sagen. Wir haben 99 Kommentare.
Welche nicht?
Nee, wir haben mehr Kommentare als bei der hochdynamischen, mit der programmatischen Sendung, ja.
Daran machst du das fest?
Und noch mehr Kommentare als Kalender für 100, und das ist eine Sendung mit Kalendern, ja. Und auch 79 hat viel weniger Kommentare. Also das Medien-Ed, das Hörerecho war quasi Podcast-lutionär.
Ja, jetzt kannst du ja nochmal die Flatter-Knöpfchen.
Die Flatter-Knöpfchen, die sind natürlich auch, also es geht steil nach oben, aber ich hab ja beobachtet.
Gibt es jetzt Flatter-Knöpfchen endlich?
Na die gibt es ja schon lange, Alter. Wo denn? Wo lebst du denn? Und an welchem Stein bist du denn gerade hervorgekochen?
Aus welchem Samsung-Produkt bist du entstanden?
Flatter-Knöpfchen gibt es doch hier bei Teeb, überall. Überall, alles voll geflattert. Da, zack, zack, nur bei den ist keiner.
Oh Gott, das ist alles voll geflattert.
Das hat mich voll geflattert. Jungs, warum hat der Hucke mehr als ich? Kann das sein?
Ja, ihr habt ja, ihr wisst ja, heute Mobile Max 83, die Sendung, wo keiner mehr durcheinander redet und alles schön diszipliniert und Ordnung herrscht.
Heute auf der Showbühne.
Leider bin ich immer noch mit demselben Team geschlagen, aber trotzdem, ich begrüße sie von rechts nach links, Roddy, Hucke, Dennis und heute mit ohne Max, denn Max ist nicht da.
Manchmal hat man, mal hat man nicht, ne?
Mal, mal genau. Heute mit ohne Max, wir grüßen Max, sollte er sich an irgendeinem von diesen Streaming-Endpunkten befinden, von denen wir annehmen, dass sie existieren. Ja, ist irgendwas passiert?
Nö.
Also es war ein ganz stinklunationärer zwei Wochen Abschnitt seit der letzten Sendung.
Wie immer, es gab nur Keynotes und Präsentationen.
Neue Eye-Photo-Themen.
Das war ja jetzt die erste echte, richtige Non-Steve-Produkt-Introduktion. Wie ging es euch dabei so?
May not contain Steve.
Boring.
Fandet ihr das boring?
Das war so boring, dass ich es nicht geguckt habe.
Als Steve noch so streichholzmäßig die letzte Forschung davon iCloud gemacht hat, da hat er ja irgendwie auch noch mal richtig Dampf, also Feuer gemacht. So hier, diesmal haben wir es richtig gemacht und so ein bisschen zackig und knackig und diesmal war halt so, ja, ist ganz nett, macht er schon gut und so, aber war irgendwie nicht so, war nicht so das gleiche Spirit.
Ich fand es erstaunlich gut, was Tim gemacht hat, weil ich dachte, der ist mehr so die Schnachnase, als es dann tatsächlich war.
Ist ja doch aber.
Aber es war nicht so gut wie Steve, also Steve hat das schon gut gekonnt.
Also mit anderen Worten, sag mal, wenn ihr Tim sagt die ganze Zeit, und Tim hat es nicht raus und Tim war früher auch besser und so.
Das geht dir ein bisschen so ans Mark, ja.
Ich bin mir nicht so sicher, wie ihr das meint.
Was denkst du jetzt?
Ich glaube, Tim Cook ist gar nicht so schlecht, ihr versucht euch da jetzt nur irgendwie so ein bisschen abzuarbeiten.
Nicht schlecht ist er nicht. Ich sag ehrlich gesagt, ich sag ja nicht, dass da irgendjemand schlecht ist. Ich sag nur, mit Steve hat mehr Spaß gemacht.
Vielleicht können wir ja mal dann auf den Inhalt kommen. Jenes Event, welches stattfand nur eine Woche her war, wo das großartige neue iPad vorgestellt wurde. Was jetzt nur noch iPad heißt.
Nein, The New iPad, bitte.
Nee, nee. Habt ihr auch so einen Moment darüber nachgegrübelt, wie das jetzt gemeint ist?
So wie bei The New iMac und so wie bei The New...
Trotzdem, man hat sich irgendwie so schnell daran gewöhnt, dass dieser ganze iKram hochgezählt wird und der mKram nicht. Aber macht eigentlich keinen Sinn. Ich glaube, die wollten sich einfach von diesem... Oh Gott, das ist nur ein 4s und kein 5s irgendwie lösen. So hier einfach iPhone frisst, wie sie dann so die drei iPhones, die sie parallel im Verkauf haben, dann allerdings künftig preisen wollen, ist mir noch nicht so ganz klar. Also entweder nimmst du ein iPhone oder ein iPhone und dann hätten wir auch noch ein iPhone.
Meinst du, das 5 heißt dann auch nicht mehr iPhone 5 jetzt, wenn was theoretisch dieses Jahr kommen sollte?
Was heißt dann The New iPhone?
Das wird nicht iPhone 5 heißen.
iPhone LTE?
Nee, das wird einfach iPhone heißen. Ja, das ist für eine Woche. Heißt es The New iPhone und danach heißt es iPhone Late 2012.
Habt ihr euch mitgerissen, war? Nee, das fand ich gut.
Seht ihr das richtig, dass wir alle nicht so richtige, totale iPad-begeisterte User sind?
Naja, ich meine, wenn man jetzt mal die letzten 82 Folgen Revue passieren lässt und dann die Episoden sich rauspickt, wo ich zum Thema iPad, als ich noch gar keins hatte, hab ich ja die ganze Zeit gesagt, Auflösung sind niedrig, kickt mich nicht. Jetzt haben sie ja für mich quasi erstmal überhaupt delivered. Ich hab zwar zu Weihnachten so ein iPad von der Firma geschenkt bekommen und ist ja auch alles ganz gut zum Spielen und so, aber jetzt ist ja das iPad eigentlich so, wie ich es vorher überhaupt haben wollte, mit ordentlich Auflösung.
Was willst du jetzt damit sagen?
Naja, für mich, also ich bin total begeistert eigentlich von diesem iPad natürlich.
Hast du eins?
Nee, aber ein Kollege hat es bestellt und es kommt wohl.
Aber ich kenn einen, der bald einen haben wird.
Ich guck's mir dann an, ja natürlich.
Hast du überhaupt schon ein iPad?
Ja, ein iPad 2. Sag mal, wo warst du die letzten drei Sendungen?
Was weiß ich, was weiß ich nicht. Du kommst ja immer mit deinem 17 Zoll, was dann geschrumpft ist, und dann erzählst du mir, seit drei Jahren hast du das nicht mehr. Ich komm da nicht hinterher bei deinem Update, zeitlos.
Also seit drei Monaten hab ich ein iPad.
Und was machst du jetzt mit dem Ding so die ganze Zeit?
Spielen, vor allen Dingen.
Spielen? Nur am Zocken?
Aber nicht vom iPad. Nee, aber also Brausen, Brausen, Lesen gelegentlich mal irgendwas, so ein Artikel oder so, aber ansonsten Primärspielen, ja. Dafür ist es auch sehr gut geeignet.
Auf Deutsch eigentlich ist das iPad eine neue Konsole.
Ja, ja, also ich mein, es gibt Leute, ja wie gesagt, hatten wir auch letztes Mal, die das total gut so produktiv benutzen können. Ich bin da noch nicht so eindeutig dabei, ja. Ich brauch ein Terminal, wie ich schon oft auch kundgetan hab. Und ja, aber zum Spielen ist super und also...
Ich glaub wir hatten das ja auch schon mal, oder?
Ja, und wenn sie da jetzt irgendwie halt, ich weiß nicht, also das ist halt schon krass zum Beispiel in der Firma, wir machen jetzt ja halt Spiele, also Facebook und jetzt eben auch auf iPhone und iPad und so. Und jetzt ist das erste Problem, unser Spiel soll jetzt ja natürlich für iPad 3 ready sein. Und in der gesamten Firma gibt es nur ein Display, was groß genug ist, um die volle, native Auflösung von diesem iPad darzustellen.
Im Simulator?
Im Simulator. Und das ist das 30 Zoll vom Chef. Der hat halt noch so ein Cinema-Display und das ist das einzige Display gerade in der Firma, was die native Auflösung vom iPad unskaliert ohne Scroll darstellt.
Aber ich wollte doch nur ein Thunderbolt-Display holen.
Nee, es hat weniger.
Ach so, hat in der Breite zwar genug, aber in der Höhe nicht.
Also das 30 Zoll ist das Einzige, was es...
Und das gibt's ja gar nicht mehr, ne?
Und das gibt's gar nicht mehr, genau. So, das heißt, der Chef hat...
Aha!
Irgendwas klingt ja aber schon wieder komisch, ne? Auf jeden Fall hat der Chef jetzt seinen 30 Zoll abgegeben für die iOS-Developer, ne? Ich mein, das ist schon krass, wenn dann auf den 30 Zoll hat er dann das Spiel hochgefahren im Simulator und es ist halt gigantomatisch groß und es sieht alles lecker, geil, scharf und so weiter aus. Und das alleine wird schon einfach total kicken an diesem Gerät. Also, um Content zu konsumieren, Fotos, Videos, Spiele. Also, ich hab jetzt bei den Spieldemos halt hinten nicht mehr zugeschaut, dann bei der Keynote, aber ich bin sicher, die waren total atemberaubend, toll und großartig und das wird schon.
Und jeder, der erstmal so ein Ding in der Hand hatte, wird nie wieder zurück. Das ist wie beim iPhone 4, da war das doch so. Einmal Retina gesehen und es gibt keinen Weg zurück, es ist einfach dicht die Tür.
Es geht nicht mehr.
Ja, wahrscheinlich.
Also, ich hoffe ja auch ernsthaft, dass sie das jetzt dann eben hinkriegen, dass es auf dem MacBook und so dann auch irgendwann mal mehr Auflösungen gibt.
Ich würde mal sagen, so diese Retina-Display, also auch schon beim iPhone, jetzt beim iPad, ist so der Moment, wo die Qualität, die, wie sagt man, die eigene Auflösung des Auges sozusagen, wo man überholt wird oder von dem, was man selber schafft zu verarbeiten. Und diesen Kick hatten wir bei Video, glaube ich, noch nicht, oder?
Nein, das Ding ist jetzt zum Beispiel...
Bei Video-Qualität meine ich jetzt, so von Filmen.
Was ich beeindruckend fand, ich hab ja eine Konferenz ja letztes Jahr, ihr erinnert euch alle, die Ruckow-Veranstaltungen, da waren wir im Kino International als Veranstaltungs-Organ. Die haben ein Digital-Projekt, auch einer der besten, die es gerade so gibt, für teuer, teuer, teuer, 100.000 Dollar. Aber der hat halt auch nur 2048 mal irgendwas und das hat halt auf die 21-Meter-Leinwand projiziert, aber es sah halt immer noch gut aus.
Ein Pixel war so groß wie eine CD.
Ja, weiß nicht, du hast die Pixel nicht so doll gesehen, wie ich vermutet hätte, also es sah gut genug aus. Und von daher, ich meine, so Full HD ist schon auch eine ganz schöne Menge Holz. Also wenn du das auf 21 Metern im Kino hoch skalieren kannst, es sieht immer noch gut aus, dann... Und du hast das hier so in einer üblicher Weise auf so einem Monitor, auf so einem kleinen Popelbeamer.
Es ist ja gar nicht so sehr, dass es so viele Pixel sind. Es ist halt wirklich die Größe, der Pixel ist entscheidend.
Dass man sie nicht mehr sieht, ist halt geil.
Ja, und dass man damit eben auch wirklich mal amtliches Frontrendering hinbekommt. Also das ist eigentlich das, wo ich am meisten vorausschaue, wie es sich als Buch macht, weil ich mochte eigentlich das Lesen auf iPad an sich schon, nur dass mir das Einsa, ich hab ja nur das Einsa, ein bisschen zu schwer war. Na, ich sah halt keinen Bedarf fürs Zweier eben genau aus diesem Grund, weil die Auflösung hat es mir dann doch verdorben. Also es war einfach so matschig.
Das iPad ist alt, hat ja schon noch ganz schön eine grobschlechtige Auflösung, oder?
Wie? Wie grobschlechtig? Na ja, halt so wie es halt bisher war.
Na ja, ist schon ganz schön hinterher so.
Gegen das iPhone 4, 4s Display ist das natürlich.
Ja, auch so gegen MacBook Pros und so. Die sind ja bei 160 oder irgendwie sowas. Das iPad, glaube ich, war bei 110 oder so.
Ja klar, aber du hältst es ja auch anders. Du hältst es ja auch noch viel näher ran. Das kommt noch dazu.
Also ich hab letztens auch noch mal ein altes in der Hand gehabt und wenn man schon bei den Fond, also bei den Zeichen irgendwie so, so einzeln die Stufen so sehen kann, sieht schon ganz schön hässlich aus.
Ja, und das, obwohl sie das Fond-Rendering ja hinbekommen haben. Hier, letztes Mal.
Mir wird gerade heiß bei dieser Resolutionsdiskussion. Ich muss mich erst mal ausziehen.
Ja, mach mal, ähm, was wollte ich jetzt gerade sagen? Verdammt, sind wir alle voll aufeinander. Kannst nicht einfach.
Geh doch einfach, Huckel.
Huckel macht jetzt hier einen Strip, Mann. Ausziehen, ausziehen. Oh Gott, das wird hier nichts sein mit Disziplin in dieser Sendung. Huckel tut auch nicht so, wir sind doch sowieso alle nackt.
Schlüpper noch und fertig, so, jetzt aber hinsetzen.
Okay, jetzt bin ich mittlerweile komplett raus. Worüber wollten wir reden? Soll ich da den Mikrofon auch wieder anmachen?
Font-Rendering haben sie irgendwo hinbekommen, meinst du?
Ja, hier letztes Mal hatten wir noch dieses komische Photoshop von Adobe, was sie ja mit R gemacht haben. Man hört dann gleich wieder so die Qualität von Cross-Platform-Frameworks. Ich hab das Ding gestartet und ich hab's einfach sofort gesehen, dass das Font-Rendering einfach im Arsch ist. Und da war ja das iPad eigentlich schon immer relativ gut, nur trotzdem hat es halt nicht gereicht. Und wenn mich das überzeugt, dann werd ich mir so ein Ding kaufen.
Und dann bei dieser Presi war ja noch hier Sketchbook Pro, das fand ich natürlich dann ganz interessant. Ich ja letzte Folge auch meinte, sie könnten ja mal da noch mit dem Stift, aber haben sie ja nicht. Immer noch die unpräzise und es sah auch in der Demo so aus, als würde der Strich auch immer noch hinterherlegen und so. Aber naja, mal gucken, mal gucken. Aber ich hatte ja so für einen Moment gedacht, jetzt sagen sie hier noch und hier für Stifte super, aber nee.
Wir wissen ja jetzt bei allen weiteren Features, die wir besprechen von dem iPad, müsst ihr dann sagen, ob ihr da überrascht wart oder nicht. Also ich glaube beim Retina-Display, da war jetzt keiner besonders geschockt.
Ich wäre geschockt gewesen, wenn es nicht gekommen wäre. Aber als dann noch mal die Zahlen von 2500, da saß ich noch mal kurz so da und dachte, das ist schon ein ganz kleiner scheiße großer Batzen Pixel.
2048.
Drei Mega Pixel. Mittlerweile werden Bildschirme so geführt, wie das vor kurzem noch mit Kameras war.
Ja, aber die Kameras zählen ja die Subpixel, insofern wären es ja neun Mega Pixel.
Ja, so dann, ach so, dann muss ich so ein bisschen in mich gehen, weil ich hätte um ein Haar noch in der letzten Sendung gewettet, dass Dennis...
Disziplin, Alter.
Du hörst zu wenig Podcasts, Dennis. Du musst eigentlich, eigentlich müsste man nicht mal dazu verdonnern.
Das kann ich nicht so ungedingst im Raum stehen lassen, weil das ist falsch.
Es kommt eine Warteschleife, es wird serialisiert. Versuch einfach mal wie Grand Central zu arbeiten.
Ich mach Multiprocessing Hardcore.
Nee, du hast nur einen Chor, aber das ist trotzdem wie Grand Central.
Aber dann kann man mit Locking hin und her switchen.
Jeder hat zehn Millisekunden Zeit zu reden.
Wenn ich rede, dann ist es gelockt. Ich bin deine Sima-Funk.
Aber da gibt es sogar Geschichten, so moderne Sachen, das heißt Lockstealing, da kann man...
Ja, das ist das, was du betreibst und ich möchte, dass du das einstellst.
So, das äußere ich mich nicht mehr dazu. Ich wollte letztes Mal fast noch wetten, dass wie auch immer der neue Prozessor heißt, dass er auf keinen Fall A5X heißt. Da habe ich natürlich nicht mit Apple gerechnet.
Mit dem neuen Tim.
Ich meinte halt was anderes.
Du meintest mit X eigentlich sowas wie S und so.
Meine eigentliche Frage war ja, nennen sie ihn halt A5 irgendwas oder nennen sie ihn A6?
So.
Und ich dachte mir nur so, egal wie sie ihn nennen, sie nennen ihn bestimmt nicht A5X, wenn er dann vier Cores hat. Dass er dann aber nur zwei Cores hat, aber trotzdem vier Cores, weil sie ja die GPU verdoppelt haben, aber den Prozessor nicht. Auf die Idee bin ich dann aber nicht gekommen. Insofern passt es vielleicht dann auch. Finde ich aber ganz cool, dass sie irgendwie da was gerissen haben. Und ist das jetzt eigentlich schon irgendwie bestätigt worden, dass das Teil einen Gigabyte RAM hat?
Wodurch?
Durch irgendein Benchmark, der das auf dem Gerät gelaufen ist.
Eine Bestätigung ist es aber noch nicht. Da meint einer, er hat das laufen lassen und das wäre so. Aber es ist noch nicht so richtig offiziell, ne? Du meinst ja Vietnameser, der dieses Geekbench gestartet hat.
Gut, wir werden das sehen. Ich halte das jetzt nicht für komplett ausgeschlossen.
Ich auch nicht, denke mal schon, es wird stimmt.
Aber das RAM ist ja mit auf dem Prozessor drauf und von daher könnte das schon bedeuten.
Echt, ist das so?
Na ja, wenn alle Bilder jetzt viermal so groß sind, brauchst du auch einen Geek, sonst geht nichts.
Ja, ja, ich halte das auch für absolut denkbar. Aber das wird sicherlich dem Gerät dann auch nochmal ordentlich Beschleunigung zukommen lassen. Wo ich dann so ein bisschen überrascht war, war wirklich die Sache mit dem 3G. Also wie sie das so da ausgestattet haben, dieses Gerät und dass sie dann auch tatsächlich schon diesen LTE-Standard aufnehmen, das hab ich jetzt nicht unbedingt kommen sehen.
Wenn auch nicht für Deutschland und so.
Wenn auch nicht für Deutschland. Also dieses LTE scheint auch mal wieder so ein totaler Frequenz-Turt zu sein. Aber ich meine, wenn ich das richtig sehe, Telekom und auch glaube ich Vodafone haben von Vodafone habe ich nichts gehört, aber ich glaube Telekom hat zumindest schon angekündigt, dass sie wohl dieses DC-HSDPR auch unterstützen können und werden. Wann und wie und wo, weiß ich nicht, aber es ist jetzt nicht so, dass sie komplett aus dem Bett gefallen sind und dann sagen, wie was denn das hier für eine Abkürzung, was uns Apple da wieder irgendwie vor die Nase hält. Die haben es ja als Dual Carrier genannt, die eigentliche, manche nennen das wohl so und manche nennen das anders, jetzt muss ich grad nochmal nachschlagen. Dual Cell, Carrier Aggregation, also heißt das, dass ich dann mit zwei Zellen gleichzeitig kommuniziere und dadurch meine Geschwindigkeit verdoppler?
Klingt so, ne? Naja, auf jeden Fall schön, dass sie das eingebaut haben. Letztens dachte ich mir, ich hab ja auch ein Dual-Dingsbums-iPad, also mit Wi-Fi und GSM. Ich hab ja zu Hause immer das GSM außer mit der Akku-Aulänge. Ich brauch's halt nicht, weil ich eh WLAN hab und ich benutze es nirgendwo anders. Letztens, als ich krank war, dachte ich, okay, jetzt geh ich mal zum Arzt und jetzt hab ich mal ein Use-Case, das 3G einzuschalten, damit ich da Internet hab. Dann ging's beim Arzt so schnell, dass ich's gar nicht ausgepackt hab und dann bin ich nach Hause und hab's gleich wieder ausgemalt. Ich hab noch nicht einen Byte über dieses 3G im iPad transportiert. Noch beleglich, aber da ist meistens dein Internet doch eh scheiße. Also wenn du im Zug bist oder im Flugzeug, wo man dann hinkommt, gibt's ja immer WLAN. Meistens.
Naja, also wenn das so ist bei dir.
Also, naja, ich mein, ich hab's ja jetzt erst 3 Monate, Tim.
Musst auf jeden Fall schwer aufpassen mit diesem Teil. Naja, ich weiß nicht, ich vergesse das immer. Ich hab da so Podcasts aufgenommen und dann hatte ich auf einmal so GSM-Störungen. Und dann dachte ich, mein Telefon ist doch aus und so. Und danach ist mir das eingefallen, dass ich auch noch dieses iPad irgendwo in der Tasche hatte. Das war dann so fast die ganze Sendung.
Ich hab dann einen iPad 3 auch ohne geordert.
Ich bin da noch so ein bisschen, mein erstes war halt nur Wi-Fi und da dachte ich mir so, hm.
Das GPS-Hilter, das ist schon ein bisschen blöd, aber da hast du immer noch über WLAN irgendwie hier Ordnung.
Kannst du das nicht mit dem Phone tetheren? Also, sag mal, angenommen...
Er hat tetheren gesagt, er hat tetheren gesagt. Gott sei Dank haben sie ja diesen Hotspot-Modus jetzt hier irgendwie auch dazu gepackt, warum sie das nicht gleich dabei hatten. Nobody knows.
Aber eigentlich will man das ja dann auch so ummachen.
Eigentlich will ich... Oder? Das ist iPhone... Ich muss noch mal kurz noch mal mit Apple kommunizieren. Tim, unter uns. Tims unter sich. Warum hat das MacBook Air kein GSM? Warum hat es kein UMTS? Warum? Warum ist dieses Scheiß Air der Travel-Computer? Den, den man immer dabei hat. Warum hat dieses Gerät immer noch kein 3G? Warum? Wieso wegen AT&T? Ich meine, wenn ich mit dem iPad rumrennen kann und mit dem iPhone, dann kann ich das doch wohl auch irgendwie mit dem Air. Wo ist der Unterschied? Da sehe ich jetzt auch in den Marktrealitäten der USA keinen Grund mehr, warum man das jetzt nicht macht. Und ich meine, wenn Apple beschließt, so ein Gerät rauszubringen, dann wird AT&T bestimmt nicht sagen, ach nee, also mit so einem Gerät können sie bei uns nicht ins Netz gehen. Won't happen. Die Zeiten sind vorbei. Und ich sehe ehrlich gesagt keinen Grund, warum das da nicht drin ist. Und nichts nervt mich mehr als diese Tesla-Kacke. Ich meine, es funktioniert irgendwie, ist schon super, aber ich brauch dann immer zwei Geräte, dann muss das Telefon immer noch geladen werden, dann hab ich es dann doch immer per USB dran, dann hab ich halt wieder Kabelgebimsel.
Und du hast ja auch nur ein USB, ne?
Nee, ich hab schon zwei USB-Ports, aber das ist halt einfach, ich will einfach mein R aufklappen.
Netz haben.
Netz haben, zackret hören, und dann nicht immer wieder Setup und einschalten und...
Bluetooth an, aus.
Ja, ich will mein Telefon vielleicht auch mal ausschalten und trotzdem Internet haben.
Nein. Nee, ich versteh das total. Also besser sagen, ich versteh es nicht, warum sie es beim Air oder nicht sowieso bei allen, weil so groß kann es ja offensichtlich nicht sein, so ein GSM-Modul. Und wenn man dann mal so den Rechner aufmacht und guckt, wie groß mittlerweile diese Boards nur noch sind, ist ja nur noch so ein Schinkenlappen so von der Größe her.
Ja, und ich zahle da auch gerne irgendwie eine beliebige Strafgebühr dafür, das ist mir echt scheißegal. Also vielleicht keine 500, aber irgendwie bei 200 fange ich jetzt nicht an zu diskutieren. Auch wenn es überzogen ist und überhaupt und Apple Tags.
120, oder?
Es ist mir so egal, Hauptsache es ist drin. Weil ich will, dass mein Mac OS-Hand selber mit dem Netz redet und nicht durch irgendein anderes Gerät. Das ist einfach, das geht nicht.
Das geht nicht.
Ja, das ist das, das hatten wir ja letztes Mal schon. Das nervt mich so ein bisschen immer mit diesem iOS und iPad. Egal, dass so viele Leute kaufen.
Gehen wir mal zum nächsten und auch noch einem der wenigen verbliebenen Wörter mit I am Anfang im Apple-Universum. Der iSight. Dass die Kamera lang warst?
Wir haben Nachgang nicht so, aber in dem Moment hätte ich auch nicht unbedingt drauf gewettet jetzt.
Okay, next. Ja, ist ganz schön mit HD-Recording und so. Ja, der Herr da. Aber was uns natürlich alle überrascht hat, ist das Dictation-Feature.
Ich fand das okay, dass sie das eingebaut haben, weil sie sich natürlich wieder nicht geäußert haben, auch wenn das sehr nahe liegt, das braucht dann wahrscheinlich auch wieder Internet. Also du kannst nicht netzlos da diktieren. Also du diktierst schon dem Apple-Server.
Ich glaube, wir können uns auch langsam davon verabschieden, dass überhaupt irgendwas ohne Internet geht. Du wirst demnächst nicht mal das kleine 1x1 rechnen lassen können ohne Internet.
Ohne Wolfram Alfa, genau.
Was mich gewundert hat, ist, dass es nicht gleich Siri hat, aber...
Es hat halt deshalb nicht Siri, weil...
Taschenrechner hat es auch nicht, oder?
Also das iPad hat meines Wissens keinen Annäherungs-Sensor drin. Der Annäherungs-Sensor spielt bei Siri eine wichtige Rolle, weil du ja dadurch automatisch schon mal aktivieren kannst. Gut, jetzt könnte man sagen, ich drücke dann halt einfach auf diese Taste und rede mit meinem Computer. Aber ich glaube, da sind wir gleich wieder voll bei creepy. Das finden die wahrscheinlich sogar selber creepy. Ich würde nicht sagen, dass Apple sich nicht noch breit schlagen lässt und Siri da auch noch mal mit einbaut. Rein technisch sehe ich jetzt keinen Grund. Gibt es irgendwas sonst noch?
Die Argumentation habe ich jetzt nicht verstanden. Warum ist Siri creepy, wenn man eine Taste drücken muss, um es zu benutzen?
Es ist völlig normal, dass du dein Telefon ans Ohr hältst und mit ihm redest. Heutzutage, das war vor 10, 15 Jahren auch mal anders, aber wenn du heutzutage dir eine Wurst im Supermarkt ans Ohr hältst und die Leute nicht drauf reagieren, wenn du anfängst, mit ihr zu sprechen, das ist einfach völlig normal.
Ich nehme immer die Banane.
Aber wenn du jetzt dein Badezimmer-Spiegel dabei hast und anfängst mit dem zu reden, dann halten dich alle gleich für Schneewittchens Mutter.
Für Spiegel-Luzionär.
Du willst das jetzt wirklich durchklingen.
Mir gelingt heute noch ein guter, ich bin sicher.
Ich bin gespannt.
Ich muss mal...
Bemühe dich, sonst haben wir wieder keinen Titel.
Titel kriegen wir auch. Ich glaube schon, ja.
Also ich denke, das sind eher solche generellen Erwägungen. Es gibt jetzt keinen technischen Grund, warum sie es nicht könnten.
Aber ich muss mal ehrlich sagen, dass ich Siri mit ans Ohr halten auch noch nie verwendet habe.
Du hast einen 4S, ja? Wie häufig benutzt du Siri so?
Selten.
Wahrscheinlich um den T-Timer zu stellen oder sowas, ne?
Aber das liegt auch daran, dass mich Siri immer nicht versteht.
Das versteht dich nicht?
Was sagst du ihm denn so? Oder ihr? Sagt man sie?
Keine Ahnung.
Ich weiß nicht. Er, sie, es?
Auf Deutsch geht's irgendwie gar nicht.
Also du redest mit S.
Mit S Deutsch. Ja, wenn ich mit S Deutsch rede, dann geht's gar nicht. Also wenn man jetzt so was machen möchte, wie einen Termin-Schedulen, dann sagt man ja, Deutsch.
Ja, gut. Einen Termin, wie heißt du das auf Deutsch? Wie heißt du das auf Deutsch? Genau, Siri fehlt das Setting für den Englisch.
Also man will einen Termin machen, sagt ja, neuer Termin, hier, dann und dann und so weiter. Und dann kommt ganz zum Schluss kommt dann die Frage Bestätigen. Und wenn du dann Bestätigen sagst, sagt Siri, ich verstehe Bestätigen nicht. Soll ich nach Bestätigen Web-Suche machen?
Ja musst du sagen!
Ich sag dir, das ist genau das, was ich am Anfang schon meinte, mit dieser ganzen Spracherkennung und Menschen und Computer.
Das sollen wir einfach sein lassen.
Ich bin mir da nicht so sicher, ob der Durchbruch schon da ist.
Nee, auf keinen Fall. Das nutzt auch keiner mehr, oder?
Ich weiß nicht, ich hab kein 4S.
Irgendwas knackt hier.
Ja, ich weiß auch schon. Aber da geh ich jetzt nicht bei.
Das macht dieses andere Tool dann für dich, ne? Ja, Siri, warum es das jetzt wirklich nur auf dem 4S gibt, das erschließt ich mir ehrlich gesagt auch nicht so ganz. Aber ich kann mir jetzt echt nicht vorstellen, dass mein Vierer nicht auch in der Lage wäre, die Processing-Power an den Tag zu legen.
Dann sei da froh, dass du den nicht hast.
Doch, ich würde mir gelegentlich gerne mal einen T-Timer stellen, jawohl.
Ach, es gab ja noch ein anderes Gerücht, und zwar, und da bin ich mir jetzt auch gar nicht so sicher, ob das iPad 3, doch wenn die diesen A5X haben, The New iPad, ob The New iPad das auch hat, und zwar habe der Prozessor, also der A5 im iPhone 4S, habe, korrigiert mich, so ein DSP-Modul. Genau.
Um Rauschunterdrückung zu machen.
Genau, um einfach so eine extrem krasse Hintergrundeliminierung dazu betreiben.
Der die beiden Mikros hier so ausnutzt und, ja.
Wüsst ihr jetzt nicht, was es ihnen bringen sollte, aus dem iPad-Prozessor diese Funktionalität rauszuhalten? Es sei denn, sie meinen halt, dass sie sie nicht brauchen.
Sie machen ja Dictation. Also ist wahrscheinlich auch der entsprechende DSP da drin.
Es ist ja eigentlich alles da. Die einzige Frage ist ja nur, leiten sie ein Kommando an den Server weiter oder nicht? Ja, das ist recht. Das hab ich ja total vergessen, natürlich, klar.
Und ich sag noch, Dictation.
Okay, ich halt's Maul. Was ich ja viel interessanter fand, ist, dass Ding jetzt irgendwie endlich die 1080p-Ära einleitet.
Wenn sie mal die 60 FPS-Ära einleiten würden.
Die was?
Die 60 FPS-Ära.
Fürs User-Interface.
Für alles.
Ja, alles. 60 FPS für alles.
Da bin ich auch sehr dafür.
48 würde ja jetzt erstmal kommen, aber...
Echt?
Ja, ich rede grundsätzlich von einem.
Du redest ja auch von 1080p, das hat ja selten was mit...
Nein, er ist schon auch von frame per second.
Ja, aber... 1080p hat auch mit Filmen zu tun, im Wesentlichen.
Mit Filmqualität, ja. Weil irgendwann nützt mir ja mehr Auflösung, nicht so, das seh ich eh nicht mehr, aber... Mehr Bilder die Sekunde würd ich schon noch erkennen.
Du meinst, dass jetzt Filme doppelt so schnell aufgehen, also mit mehr Frames kommen, gibt's denn sowas schon?
Ich mein, ja. Noch nicht, aber bald. Der Hobbit wird in 48 FPS gedreht und kommt auch so in die Kinos.
So langsam sind die Festplatten groß genug und so.
Der kommt so in die Kinos. In welche Kinos kommt der denn rein?
In die Digital-Kinos.
Und die können das?
Ich hoffe. Wenn nicht, geh ich in eine andere Schiene.
Ja klar, die Digital-Projektoren, die können das garantiert.
Die können ja auch 3D, da müssen ja auch schon...
Die müssen halt zwischendurch wahrscheinlich immer so die zwei Terabyte-Platten so rauswechseln, so wie damals die großen Filme rollen. Aber prinzipiell müssten die das auf jeden Fall abspielen können.
Hab ich das erzählt? Ein Freund von mir, der hat irgendwie, wollte eine der Premieren von Avatar sich angucken, war irgendwie im großen Kino, ich glaube hier, Zoopalast. Ausverkauftes Haus, 500 Leute. Und als der Film dann losgehen sollte, musste sich die Chefin von dem Kino vornehin stellen und sagen, es tut uns fürchterlich leid, wir haben den Film mit seinen 17 Terabyte oder wie viel der da hat, auf Platte, aber sie haben uns nicht den Key geschickt.
Das war doch groß in allen Zeitungen.
Ja, er war dabei, er meinte, es war schon...
Wann war das? Zur Premiere?
Zur Premiere, ja. Und er meinte, er hat bewundert, dass sich die Frau tatsächlich vorne vor alle Leute gestellt hat und das gesagt hat. Und dann mussten sie halt 500 Karten umtauschen. Und das gab dann irgendwie Ärger.
Dabei hätten sie doch nur das MacBook Pro anschließen müssen.
Naja, also auf jeden Fall, da gibt's auch so Seiten, wo man sehen kann, was zum Beispiel bei bestimmten Szenen so mehr Frames pro Sekunde bringt. Also immer so, wenn die Kamera so mitschwenkt, so bei Verfolgungsjagden, Autofahrten, irgendwas durch die Szenerie, jemand reitet quer durchs Bild. Wenn man da so einzelnen Frame-by-Frame durchsteppt, sieht man halt, dass dann so ein Frame wirklich nur so ein verwaschener Swoosh ist. Und dann hast du daneben halt doppelt so viele Frames und das ist so eine richtig brillante, anmutende, grazile Bewegung. Nicht so ein Schuck, Schuck, Schuck.
Und dann machen sie nur 48?
Nein, wie gesagt, die Datenmengen sind halt krass. Also das ist eigentlich der Haupthinderung.
Aber der Trend geht zu 96.
Frames pro Sekunde.
Hoffe ich doch.
Würde ich mal sagen.
Also bei 48 ist mein Auge auf jeden Fall noch schneller.
Ich glaube auch, das ist jetzt so richtig vage, aber als ich das auch mal so nachgeschrieben habe, glaube ich, stand irgendwo, dass man bis zu 100 Frames pro Sekunde könnte man wohl auch mit dem Auge, aber weiß ich nicht, kann auch total falsch sein.
Aber auch so allein um die Standbildqualität auch mal zu verbessern. Ja, wir wollen bessere Standbilder haben.
Naja, du willst halt, willst halt mal eine Pause, und dann soll halt das Auto, was da gerade mit 300 Kameras über den Highway gerast ist, soll halt einfach brillant, kristallscharf...
Siehst du richtig, wie so die Zunge beim Schauspieler so aus dem Mund raus, und der kleine Käfer gerade an die Windschutzscheibe zerschellt. Die ganzen blöden Gesichter, die dir in dem Moment machen... Zurück zum iPad Airplay 1080p. Ich bin ja mal gespannt, wie das so performt über so die gängigen WLANs, also ob das so wirklich latenzfrei genug ist, um wirklich genießbar zu sein. Aber ich habe mir natürlich sofort so eine neue Apple TV gekauft, weil das natürlich natürlich auch ein super Zuspielgerät ist, jetzt für einen Beamer. Du klingelst, Dennis.
Mitten in der Sendung.
Ja, ein Knopf ist ja kaputt zum Abschalten.
Wie kann man eigentlich beim iPhone einen Call ablehnen?
Da oben drücken, einmal drücken, dann kriegen sie es nicht mit, sondern es hört nur auf zu klingeln und bei denen klingelt es aber weiter. Das heißt, nur das klingelt nicht aus. Und wenn du zweimal drückst, dann werden sie automatisch zur Mailbox weitergeleitet. Hast du nicht gewusst, was? Das geht doch schon seit Tag Null.
Und kann man auch ablehnen?
Ja, dann gehst du einfach ins Slider und sagst no, oder? Also das ist ein grün und ein roter Button. Nee, das ist doch ein grün und ein roter Button. Wenn es klingelt, ist ja nicht mehr gelockt, dann ist es ein grün und ein roter Button.
Nee, klar ist es immer noch der Slider.
Ist immer noch der Slider, ruf mich mal an.
Wir forschen da. Aber ich dachte, du kannst den ablehnen mit dem Lock-Button. Also weiter klingeln lassen, das mache ich immer mit Minus-Button, also Volume-Button mache ich einfach nur leise.
Genau.
Und ich dachte, mit dem Lock-Button machst du es ablehnen.
Dem Lock-Button? Und wenn der Lock-Button schon gelockt ist?
Nee, ja, dann trotzdem ablehnen. Kannst ja mal probieren. Einfach hier oben einmal, nee hier, den da.
Ach so, der. Na, das werden wir jetzt gleich sehen. Ich warte jetzt auf den Ruf.
Ich calle das die ganze Zeit.
Wen rufst du an?
Na dich.
Bist du sicher?
Ich glaube schon.
Ja, es steht da, Calling iPhone.
Ja, Calling, das heißt, er ist noch im Aufbau.
Irgendjemand ist rangegangen, aber es ist nicht Tim.
Du hast mir wahrscheinlich zu Hause irgendwo angerufen.
Seid ihr sicher, dass ihr nicht alle den Flugmodus anhabt?
Da ist eine Mailbox rangegangen.
Ich bin gerade nicht eingebucht.
Na toll, Tim.
Ja, das ist nämlich der Grund. Es ist nämlich, mein iPhone ist kaputt.
Also deins auch?
Schon wieder? Ja, immer noch. Ich hab ja alles jetzt abgewartet. iOS-Update und irgendwie Clean Install und Pipapo. Und das Ding ist einfach braun. Ich werd dem nicht zum Apple Store auf Knien rutschen und sagen, ja, schlagt mich, ich hab keinen Apple Care gekauft, aber jetzt gib mir ein neues. Ja, das ist wirklich, also dieses Gerät ist sowas von bekloppt kaputt.
Kann ich deinen Taster oben haben?
Reimbursen hier, das...
Ja, mir droht das mit dem MacBook.
Dieses Telefon vergisst, dass es WLAN hat.
Das vergisst gerade, dass es dir selber hat.
Ich meine nicht, dass er nicht in einem Netz ist, sondern der ganze WLAN-Punkt ist ausgegraut, als wäre gar kein WLAN-Chip eingebaut.
Steckerlose.
Der WLAN-Stecker.
Das ist ja nicht das Einzige, dieses Gerät.
Das bootet auch irgendwie so von Zeit zu Zeit oder schaltet sich einfach aus. Einfach so irgendwie.
Hast du dir da dein Kind angegeben zum Spielen?
Nein, nein.
Die haben da reingesabbert bestimmt.
Hast du beim Tauchen beigehabt?
Ja, jetzt hat er auch gerade wieder...
Ins Klo gefallen. Kenn ich Leute, denen das passiert ist.
Naja, bleiben wir nochmal kurz bei Airplay und eben Apple TV. Ich finde, das Teil ist ein super Zuspielgerät. Spätestens dann eben mit Mountainline.
Spätestens, wenn man überhaupt ein Fernseher hat, an dem man es anschließen kann.
Ja, aber vor allem so diese Bima-Zuspiel-Problematik, finde ich gerade interessant. Also gerade, stell dir mal vor, du hast so eine Präsentationssituation, mehrere Leute, was weiß ich hier, so Kongress, 5 Minuten Lightning-Talks, ja permanent muss irgendwie Bima Zugriff.
Die Nerds beim Kongress haben aber kein Mac mit.
Naja, dass denen nicht zu helfen ist mir schon klar, aber wenn du jetzt so ein ordentliches, sane Setup hast und die Leute nur mit Macs ankommen, dann funktioniert das halt. Soweit man das benutzen kann, benutze ich das.
Also was mich ja mal interessieren würde, kann ich dann von meinem Rechner da auch hin airplaneen?
Also ich würde sagen, das hängt ein bisschen von deinem Player ab. Aber im Prinzip kannst du das Video natürlich transkodieren, sodass die Subtitles drin sind und dann schickst du das transkodierte Video rüber.
Wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist ja bei Mountain Line Airplay auch ein Systemdienst, den jetzt jedes Programm benutzen kann, oder?
Ja, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe, ist es halt auch so wie beim iOS, dass dieses AV-Media-Framework dir halt den Ausgang zu dem Airplay hin bietet und du da einfach deine Medien drauf wirfst und dann geht das.
Genau, das heißt, wir werden alle möglichen Player haben, die über Airplay die Filme so abspielen, vielleicht auch VLC oder so.
Dann muss ich mir also doch irgendwann Mountain Line... Ich wollte es ja außerhalb, ich wollte ja keine Apple-Betriebssysteme mehr installieren, jetzt bis...
Haben wir einen höheren Rekord eigentlich?
Es kann nur noch besser werden.
Über 600. Das sind 650, schon drüber, 660, oder?
Jetzt mal schnell ein paar Amazon-Effekte links in die Runde werfen. Die Gelegenheit ist günstig.
Kauft sie jetzt.
Willkommen bei der...
Wir haben noch Apple TV, jetzt neu mit 1080p, demnächst auch mit 48 frames pro Sekunde. Kaufen sie jetzt ein. Wir haben noch fünf Geräte im Shop.
Rufen sie jetzt an und sie kriegen noch ein günstiges Keramikmesser dazu.
Wählen sie die Nummer, die neben ihrer Leitungsplanke steht.
So, jetzt hier, aber weiter im Takt.
Weiter im Takt. Ich wollte noch mal kurz einen kleinen Bogen schlagen, weil du mich so ein bisschen missverstanden hast, beziehungsweise einfach über was anderes geredet hast. Was auch okay ist mit diesen frames pro Sekunde. Mit 60 frames pro Sekunde. Meinte ich ja im User-Interface. Ich weiß nicht, ob du weißt, was ich meine. Ich hätte gern meinen. Ja, was mein ich denn?
Im User-Interface gibt es ja auch ein Limit auf 30, glaube ich sogar. Oder reden wir jetzt immer noch über was anderes?
Das weiß ich nicht.
Wir hatten es ja heute schon, wir haben ein bisschen vor der Sendung, wir müssen auch Sachen mal ohne die Hörer bequatschen. Wir müssen über dieses Quarz-Debug-Tool erzählen, was man mit Xcode jetzt nachzulernen kann und so weiter und so fort. Und da gibt es ja den Frame-O-Meter, das ist ja mein Lieblingstool, weil es so smooth sieht einfach schick aus. Das ist ein kleiner Tacho, der zeigt dir an, wie viele Frames auf deinem Display gerade geupdatet werden pro Sekunde. Und wenn man normal Fenster ein- und herschiebt, ich glaube, der macht bei 30 Frames die Sekunde, schlägt er an. Ich weiß auch nicht, ob es jetzt inzwischen dann doch auch 60 sind, aber es war mal eine Weile lang bei 30, war einfach mehr.
Es gibt da ein Maximum. Ich finde ja, es müsste ein Minimum geben. Also ich finde ja auch, alle User-Interface-Elemente müssen sich mindestens mit 50 Hertz bewegen.
Also bei mir geht es bis 60.
Na dann haben sie es jetzt geändert. Ich glaube, das war mal bis 30 irgendwie.
Maximal.
Ja, es geht auf jeden Fall nicht viel drüber. Also nicht.
Ich weiß, man soll da auf jeden Fall alles so realtime-ig sein.
Ich weiß, man soll ja auch nicht so viel über Programmieren reden, aber ich mache es jetzt trotzdem. Wenn du jetzt irgendwie dein Programmchen machst und du jagst in einer Schleife 100.000-mal die Sekunde irgendeinen Wert ins Display, dann zeichnet der das da auch nicht immer rein, sondern er macht es auch nur, glaube ich, dann diese 60-mal die Sekunde, weil es ja bekloppt ist, weil so schnell kann eh keiner gucken.
Na gut, mehr als 60 ist vielleicht auch nicht wichtig, aber mir geht es mehr ums Minimum als ums...
Ja, beim Minimum, wenn die Programme nichts updaten oder nichts upzudaten haben, dann steht halt das Bild einfach, das ist ja okay. Also wie willst du ein Minimum? Du kannst ja die Programme nicht zwingen, jetzt neu zu malen, wenn da nichts neu zu malen ist.
Nein, nein, nein, gut, nein, nein, das soll ja nicht das Programm machen, sondern das Betriebssystem soll für eine flüssige Animation sorgen... In jedem Fall. Nö, das laggt manchmal einfach. Kennst du das nicht? Ziehst du irgendwo so ein Fenster um und dann dauert das.
Wenn ich bei Xcode auf Fullscreen klicke, da kannst du sogar zugucken, wie das da so hoch schmiert und wie er noch eine Sekunde braucht, um dann die kaputten Flächen, die er da hingezaubert hat, alle wieder nachzupinseln.
Zu dem kleinen, zu dem Thema noch, man kann bei diesem Quartz-Debug also tatsächlich auch das Beam-Sync ausschalten.
Beam-Sync?
Also du hast ja, wenn du ein Display hast, hast du für dieses Display eine Wiederholrate. Bildaufbau alle 60 Sekunden, 60 mal in der Sekunde natürlich. Und es hat jetzt natürlich wenig Sinn, die Grafik schneller aufzubauen, als du überhaupt hinterher auf dem Display das darstellst. Das stimmt. Jetzt scheint hier, also zumindest bei mir auf dem Display, der Sync irgendwie bei 60 Hertz zu sein. Und wenn der Beam-Sync hier auf Automatic steht, dann macht er halt bei 60 Schluss. Wenn ich den auf Disable stelle, dann kommt er bis 70.
Disable.
Disable, meinetwegen.
Du weißt aber auch, wofür das noch da ist. Das Beam-Sync oder auch Vertical-Sync genannt, ist ja wohl das Gleiche, richtig?
Ja, wahrscheinlich, ja.
Dass wenn du halt dein Fenster hier zur Seite schiebst, dass du keine Streifen reinkriegst. Dass du keine Streifen mitten im Fenster hast, dass die obere Hälfte von dem Fenster noch links ist und die untere Hälfte, weil dann genau der Refresh vom Bild kam, die untere Hälfte vom Windows dann irgendwie rechts, weil das sieht halt immer total bekloppt aus und es gibt auch ganz viele Games und so, die das irgendwie alle falsch machen und das sieht irgendwie total schlimm aus, das hasse ich. Dann lieber irgendwie Fausung einschalten, die Framerate auf 60 FPS festnageln, anstatt bei Krumm 71 zu landen oder wo auch immer und dann ist alles schick. Aber ja, viele Leute stören das halt irgendwie auch gar nicht. Wenn ich sowas sehe, ich kriege die Krise.
Naja, aber die Frage ist ja, also die eigentliche Frage, die Tim ja stellen wollte, aber nicht gestellt hat, ist, glaube ich, ist, ob der Grafikprozessor überhaupt in der Lage ist, die vierfache Pixel-Anzahl zu pushen, die er für das neue iPad braucht.
Aber dafür hat es doch den Quad-GPU-Dingens da.
Ja, aber der war vorher doch dual, ne? Und wenn ich jetzt viermal so viele Pixel habe, aber nur zwei Core mehr, also doppelt so viele Cores?
Ja, es ist ja nicht nur mehr Cores, sondern es ist ja dann auch so die nächste Generation.
Naja, schon.
Aber die nächste Generation ist aber nicht doppelt so schnell.
Trotzdem will ich das erst mit eigenen Augen gesehen haben, dass es nicht vielleicht doch irgendwo ruckelt.
Ja, also mit eigenen Augen gesehen haben will ich das auch und das wird sich sicherlich einstellen. Und ich glaube, bei der nächsten Sendung können wir dann schon deutlich mehr von sich geben. Ansonsten könnte Apple durchaus mal mehr auf unsere Release-Dates hier acht geben, damit das mal besser passt. So, wir können ja vielleicht dieses Apple TV und iPad-Thema abschließen, indem wir vielleicht noch mal kurz über Geld reden. Also ich will jetzt hier nicht die ganze Preisliste runterbeten, aber es ist natürlich interessant zu sehen, dass wir es geschafft haben, jetzt quasi 100 Euro billiger zu sein für den iPad-Einsteiger, dem es egal ist, ob das nun ein iPad 2 oder ein New iPad ist.
Das 2 ist, dafür will ich rauskommen.
Was so ein bisschen unter dem Radar war, war so die Tatsache, dass jetzt auf diesem Apple TV, das hat ja ein neues User Interface bekommen. Habt ihr das schon mal gesehen, wahrscheinlich auf Screenshots. Ich hab das mal ausprobiert auf meinem, äh hässlich, ich weiß nicht, es ist wieder mal noch etwas benutzbarer und übersichtlicher als das vorher der Fall war. Also man merkt richtig, wie sie sich da durchquälen. Wievielte Iteration ist das? Ich glaube, das ist jetzt die, ist das die dritte oder schon die vierte Variante?
Unendlich.
Bin mir nicht ganz sicher, aber mindestens die dritte. Ganz am Anfang war es ja noch, wie hieß es noch?
Front Row.
Genau. Und so ähnlich sah es auch auf dem Apple TV aus. Dann haben sie das alles weggeschmissen und durch dieses kachelige, covergefüllte System ersetzt, was jetzt da ist, im Prinzip ist das auch immer noch so, nur dass sie eben dieses Hauptmenü irgendwie weggeschmissen haben. Und ersetzt wird das Ganze mehr durch so Knöpfchen. Und der Punkt ist, du kommst halt dieser Hauptteile mit Audio, Video, etc., wird unten eben durch so eine ganze Batterie von weiteren Knöpfchen gemacht, wo dann auch so Podcasts dabei sind zum Beispiel, aber eben auch diese Ups, die da jetzt schon drauf sind. Diese Basketball League, Netzchlägs, etc.,
Die wollen natürlich auch das Apple TV, weil wenn sie natürlich hier in den Multimillionen-User-Markt gehen für Leute, die sich halt ein TV kaufen wollen, ein richtiges mit Display und so, dann wollen natürlich an denen auch mehr Geld verdienen als nur an dem Gerät selbst und da soll halt der App-Markt funktionieren.
Also ich weiß nicht, ob dieses Jahr noch ein Apple Fernseher rauskommt, aber wenn er rauskommt, ist es klar, dass der halt genauso funktioniert, wie ein Apple TV jetzt auch im User-Interface.
Aber dann macht es ja auch langsam Sinn, Apps verkaufen.
Zumindest weitestgehend.
Ja, also die werden das jetzt nicht in zwei unterschiedliche Richtungen machen.
Klicken sie die App neben ihrer Landespartnerin.
Ja, ihr könnt ja auch gleich Spiele und alles...
Ist man da jetzt noch ein Orakel, wenn man das mal festhält, dass selbstverständlich der App-Markt auf diesem Fernseher genauso einen ähnlichen Impact haben wird, wie das eben jetzt auch bei den mobilen Devices ist.
Nein, das ist kein Orakel.
Bei Apple wird das Fernsehen im Wesentlichen als App kommen. Es kann sein, dass eine App mehrere Kanäle anbietet.
Kaufen sie jetzt den ZDF-Kanal.
Aber vor allem ist es interaktiv und es bereitet dir quasi den Content auch auf. Es ist mehr als nur ein Videostrom. Es ist halt ein Informationsstrom, der dafür gedacht ist, auf einem großen Bildschirm für viele Leute sichtbar und vom Sofa aus steuerbar angezeigt zu werden. Und das zeigt halt dieses Apple TV Update schon relativ deutlich. Und was das Geld betrifft, ist es interessant. Es gab nämlich eine kleine Änderung, dass du nämlich jetzt diese Major League Basketball-Geschichte als auch Netflix mit deinem Apple-Account nutzen kannst. Das heißt, du musst keinen Netflix-Account haben, sondern über das Apple-Payment läuft jetzt auch das. Ob das jetzt etwas ist, wo die endlich eingewilligt haben, oder ob das so ist, dass Apple denen die Pistole auf die Brust gesagt hat, wenn ihr auf diesem Gerät verbleiben wollt, dann ist das jetzt the way to go. Keine Ahnung, aber ich glaube, das ist das Modell, was Apple im Sinn hat. Wie wieder mal hier 70 30 oder was auch immer die Aufteilung an der Stelle sein wird, aber du kriegst von Apple den Zugang zum Fernseher, du kannst da deine App platzieren etc. Ob es dann auch bald zum App Store kommen wird, keine Ahnung, wahrscheinlich eher nicht. Bleibt spannend.
Ich war ja ein großer Front-Row-Fan, weil ich da die ganze Zeit Trailer geguckt habe und war ja sehr traurig, als auf dem Lion das Front-Row nicht mehr ging. Jetzt habe ich mir aber über, ich weiß nicht, ob ich es schon mal erzählt habe, aber es gibt im Internet so einen Installer, da kann man sich wieder das Front-Row auf dem Lion startklammern. Jetzt habe ich wieder das Front-Row, kann ein Trailer gucken. Das Original, also er kopiert wieder die Frameworks an die richtigen Stelle. Falls wir mal wieder Trailer im Front-Row brauchen, für nichts anderes habe ich das jemals benutzt, aber dafür ist es echt gut. Ja, wollte ich nur mal gesagt haben, wenn er dann nach Google, Line, Front-Row findet er schon was.
Dann gab es noch so ein paar Applikationen, iPhoto für iOS, ich glaube, da müssen wir uns nicht so lange mit aufhalten, oder? Das ist für niemanden was, oder?
Na ja, gut, da ist halt nur dieses Ding, dass da diese neuen Apple-Karten drin sind.
Die Maps?
Maps.
Hat er es nicht erwartet.
Da sind die neuen, diese neuen Apple-Maps drin. Ich hab jetzt irgendwo gelesen, dass da hat sich jemand fürchterlich aufgeregt, dass Apple da ja nur Open-Street-Map geklaut hätte.
Na ja, fürchterlich aufgeregt ist auch nochmal anders, oder?
Ist das nicht der Sinn von Open-Street-Map?
Nee, benutzt ohne Credit zu geben. Das ist ja die einzige Auflage bei Open-Street-Map.
Benutzt ohne Credit zu geben und vor allen Dingen ein Jahr alt.
Was heißt, ohne Credit zu geben?
Na, dass du irgendwo in deinen Legal Terms auf irgendwas mal erwähnst, dass übrigens das Kartenmaterial von Open-Street-Maps kommt. Das ist eigentlich alles.
Ja, kam das auf Basis der Präsentation oder auf Basis des tatsächlich ausgelieferten iPhoto, wie man sich das jetzt runterladen kann? Also ist das jetzt immer noch in der Applikation so?
Ja, die haben halt in der Applikation sozusagen irgendwie sich Teile rausgesucht und dann irgendwie mit Proxy geguckt, wo es überhaupt herkommt, und dann haben sie irgendwie selber sozusagen sich mal Teils von Apple abgeholt und das mit OpenStreetMap-Karten übereinander gelegt, und dann gibt es so Webseiten, da kannst du dann mit so einem Slider OpenStreetMap und AppleMap übereinander sliden. Und dann siehst du halt, dass zum Beispiel manche alten Daten von OpenStreetMap, wo noch Wege falsch getaggt sind, halt eins zu eins so in AppleMaps auch drin sind und so. Also ich würde das jetzt mal noch nicht als wasserdicht, 100-prozentig oder 1000-prozentigen oder was auch immer Beweis hernehmen, aber es sieht schon sehr danach aus, als wäre es von OpenStreetMap. Bin auch mal gespannt, ob sie das nicht vielleicht mal irgendwie noch zugehen wollen. Übrigens, jetzt hier so mal als kleiner Breaker zwischendurch, wie wärs denn mal mit einer Mate-Runde, Dennis? Stehst doch gerade. Du willst ja auch eine Mate, gibst doch zu.
Du willst es doch auch.
Ich leite mir das gerade mal runter hier, dieses iPhoto, ich hab das noch gar nicht installiert gehabt. Das läuft ja auch auf dem iPhone, interessanterweise. Demonstriert haben sie es nicht. Ja, es gab ja noch so diverse andere Updates hier mit Garageband und mit irgendwie, wir können jetzt im Netzwerk spielen. Aber wenn ich Garageband höre, dann lauf ich schon davon. Das mit den Maps ist natürlich sehr interessant. Weil mich würde es ja auch keine Sekunde mittlerweile überraschen, wenn sie Google den Arsch tritt geben, wo sie nur können. Aber ich glaube, die sind wirklich... Am Anfang hab ich ja noch, als die ersten Anzeichen kamen, hab ich echt dran gezweifelt. Ich dachte, das kann doch nicht sein. Aber mittlerweile sind sie wirklich thermonuclear.
Irgendwo hieß es auch, auf der gesamten Webseite, die das neue iPad zeigt, haben sie auch nicht ein einziges Promotional-Foto, was Google Maps zeigt. Oder überhaupt Maps.
Aber es ist halt auch, was ich gelesen hab, dazu zu sagen, dass Google jetzt halt für Maps chargern will. Also es ist ja so, sie haben jetzt schon ein Monatarisierungsmodell vorgestellt für Google Maps. Also es ist jetzt nicht mehr frei für alle, sondern es ist jetzt nur noch frei für 25.000 Views pro Tag. Also für eher kleine Webseiten. Und darüber hinaus kannst du dir immer so 5.000 Views, Pakete sozusagen, kosten dann einen Dollar, noch irgendwas. Und das ist halt für so bestimmte Webseiten immer noch schwinglich genug und cool genug und so. Aber für Apple oder so was wie Foursquare und so ist dann irgendwann ganz schnell mal ein dicker Batzen Geld da.
Ja Foursquare ist ja jetzt gerade umgestiegen.
Genau und Foursquare, ja auch nicht alles, aber auf ihrer Webseite, auf ihrer Web-App benutzen sie Open Street Map und ich glaube woanders benutzen sie immer noch Google Maps. Aber das ist wohl so der Hintergrund, warum wir halt auch immer mehr jetzt mal nach Alternativen schauen, weil jetzt eben Google mal Geld für ihre Maps haben wollen. Und dann ist das auch alles gar nicht mehr so thermonuklearer War, sondern irgendwie, ja, wenn es jetzt auch, machen wir doch selber dann.
Apple wird da sicherlich einen anderen Deal haben und davon abgesehen auch natürlich einen ganz anderen Hebel. Also ich glaube, Google hat dann größeres Interesse daran, dass die Maps im iOS sind. Aber das könnte ja bedeuten, dass sie mit iOS 6 im Prinzip komplett Google Maps rausschmeißen. Das ist das, was sich jetzt abzeichnet.
Sie kriegen ja auch nicht alle Features von Google Maps an.
Und dann Apple Street View, meine ich.
Apple View.
Die Street View ist eine gute Frage, was sie da machen.
Weil ein Open Street View gibt es ja auch immer noch nicht.
Das stimmt.
Apple sagt seinen Jüngern einfach, die sollen alle mal ein Bild machen und dann haben die innerhalb von zwei Tagen eine bessere Datenbank als Google. Und du wirst sehen, wie sie alle loswerden, wie die bekloppten und die Straßen sind voll von Leuten, die mit ihren iPhones Bilder machen.
Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Jetzt mit dem iPad mit Full HD-Video und so fahren sie einfach alle lang und... Nee, aber das Problem bei OpenStreetMap ist halt, es performt nicht. Das heißt, sie müssten schon ihre eigene Serverfarm natürlich trotzdem haben.
Das werden sie sicherlich tun.
Und ihren eigenen Teil-Renderer haben sie ja dann eh das wahrscheinlich noch der leichtere Teil und dann ist mal so die Frage, ob sie dann auch zurückkontributen und so.
Wenn es irgendetwas gibt, was sie sich sicherlich nicht aus der Hand nehmen lassen, an der Stelle ist das Rendering.
Ja, klar, es ist ja alles auch möglich und einfach, aber ich sag nur, das ist jetzt Open Street Map so an sich ist ja schon auch eigentlich eins der coolsten Projekte im ganzen Internet, aber auch wahrscheinlich eins, was noch so am wenigsten Publicity für Funding und so weiter bekommen hat. Also wenn jemand mal zu viel Geld auf der Ruhenkante hat, schickt das doch den Open Street Map Jungs, weil... Wenn Apple das mal benutzt können, die das ja mal gleich machen, oder? Da bin ich auf jeden Fall gespannt, ob sie sagen, wir benutzen Open Street Map und B, wir supporten das jetzt, oder... Ach, übrigens, wir haben jetzt die Lead-Developer alle eingekauft, und das ist so wie bei Kups oder...
Das kann natürlich auch passieren, ja.
Solange die Karten immer noch und alles, aber egal. Also ich will es fast irgendwie gar nicht weiterformulieren, den Satz. Aber ich bin mal gespannt, ob es da noch ein bisschen was zu gibt, oder ob sie sagen, nee, stimmt gar nicht, alles und das. Ja, alles meins außer deins.
Gab es noch irgendwas bei diesem Event, was jetzt der Erwähnung wert wäre? Komische Spiel-Demos und kein Steve.
Vor allen Dingen kam ja dann auf Twitter dieser Ausschnitt, wo er sagt, bei der iPhone Vorstellung, so mit dem Stylus irgendwie, how are you going to use it? Was ist Stylus, right? Und dann kommt der Stylus und alle so, Stylus, naja, of course not. Und dann, ja, das war dann schon wieder so eine Szene mit Steve, wo ich dachte, ach ja, das war schon was anderes vom Flow.
Ja, in Other News, lass uns mal wieder mehr über Max reden.
Ja, andere News jetzt mal hier, jetzt wo wir hier so über Produkte so geredet haben, jetzt lass uns noch mal kurz erwähnen. Ich lese ja immer Hacker News, auch wenn da eigentlich 90 Prozent, sagen wir vielleicht sogar 95 Prozent der Zeit eigentlich totaler Bullshit da drüber scrollt, also news.ycombinator.com, Hacker News von Paul Graham und so, dieses Portal wo da, kennt ihr alle, muss ich nicht erklären. Ja, es ist halt so eine Seite, also Reddit ist mir ja zu krass, weil da kommt einfach zu viel Content durchgescrollt, aber Hacker News ist immer so, wie viele Storys sind das, 50 oder so auf einen Schlag, so oder 30 sogar nur. Und du kannst halt eine Story submitten, ähnlich wie bei Slashdot und dann wird die halt hochgevoted oder auch nicht und man kann es noch kommentieren. Also das ist im Prinzip wie Slashdot früher nur ein bisschen aufgeräumter und so ein bisschen mehr Start-up-New-Technology-lastig. Und meistens kommt da halt schon mittlerweile eigentlich nur Krempel, aber letztens kam ein Post, der war richtig Gold wert. Und zwar war der aus dem Detrace-Blog. Ich paste mal den Link jetzt nochmal in den Chat, damit es in die Show Notes, Wink, Wink, Natschnatsch, überführt werden kann. Und was da sozusagen präsentiert wird, sind coole Tools, die Command Line Tools oder Skripte, mit denen man Detrace so richtig mal testfahren kann. Und zwar hab ich vor langer Zeit schon mal auf…
Siri, was ist Detrace?
Ja Moment, ich komm ja zu Moment.
Jetzt lass den Jungen nochmal ausreden.
Und zwar war es nämlich so, dass ich schon mal vor langer Zeit auf Stack Overflow einen Post gefunden hab, wo die zehn nützlichsten USX Terminal-Commandos kamen. Und eins davon kannte ich nicht und das hieß Open Snoop. Und Open Snoop zeigt dir halt an, welche Programme gerade welche Files offen haben oder welche Files gerade von welchen Programmen accessed werden. Und das kann man auch so mit unterschiedlichen Optionen fahren. Das ist eigentlich ganz geil, immer wenn man so diesen Moment hat. Finder kann jetzt den Papierkorb oder die Disk nicht ejecten, weil dann nach irgendeinem Programm einen File benutzt oder so. Alles klar, kannst du halt mit Open Snoop gucken. Wer benutzt jetzt hier bitte noch einen File auf dieser Disk und... Open Snoop.
Alle geben gerade weltweit Open Snoop ein. Die Server berechnen unter der Last zusammen.
Brauchst der Sudo für das Open Snoop. Und es stellt sich raus, das hab ich jetzt durch diesen Post allerdings auch erst erfahren, dass dieses Open Snoop im Prinzip auch dieses D-Trace benutzt. Und D-Trace, Dennis kann das viel besser erklären. Scheiße, ich kann das gar nicht. Also doch, noch mal, Dennis.
D-Trace.
Ich bin mir nicht 100% sicher, ob ich tatsächlich verstanden hab, wie es D-Trace so alles macht.
D-Trace ist halt so ein Kernel-Level-System, was halt zahlreiche Trace-Möglichkeiten bietet. Also früher gab es ja unter Unix S Trace, mit dem man halt so System-Calls abfangen konnte. Wenn du wissen wolltest, was macht dein Programm tatsächlich mit den Betriebssystemen, dann konntest du zumindest die ganzen Einstiegspunkte, wo dein Programm in den Kernel geht, sagen lassen. Jetzt wird Open gemacht, jetzt wird das gemacht, jetzt wird das gemacht. Und D-Trace ist im Prinzip so S Trace on Stereo, wie man so schön sagt. Das heißt, es bietet alle möglichen Punkte im Kernel an, die man eben auch überwachen kann, ist dabei aber auch irgendwie mega latenzfrei. Und an der Stelle steige ich dann auch aus.
Du kannst halt in deine Programme auch überall so eine D-Trace-Probes einbauen. Und die kosten halt keine extra Performance, wenn du D-Trace nicht anhast. Und wenn du D-Trace anhast, ist es halt, also wenn du sozusagen darauf lauscht auf diese Probes, dass die triggern, kostet es halt auch nur minimalen Overhead. Und das ist wohl super cool. Und das kommt halt aus der Solaris-Welt und so. Und war dann auch in FreeBSD drin. Und da ja unter unserem geliebten OS X auch ein BSD im Prinzip noch im Fluffpelz. Ja, das BSD im Fluffpelz schlummert. Haben wir halt auch glücklicherweise dieses Detrace bekommen. Wenn man zum Beispiel mit Xcode Instruments benutzt, dann ist das genau das Gleiche, dass dann eben deine OS X ab oder in dein Projekt halt diese Probes reingeschmiert werden oder schon durch die Frameworks automatisch drin sind. Und du dann eben tracen kannst, wann Objekte alluziert werden und so weiter und so fort. Und im Prinzip ist jetzt diese Seite, das sind halt so 10 Top 10 Detray-Skripts im Prinzip, nutzen die halt auch schon tausende Probes, die an allen möglichen Stellen im OS einfach mit drin sind. Wenn du dann eben das Detray anschaltest, dann kannst du diese Probes abgreifen. Und in üblicher Weise kannst du dann eben deine eigenen Skripte schreiben, um das sozusagen so abzufischen. Und es gibt jetzt eben schon, wie OpenSnoop fertige Tools, die bestimmte Use-Cases abfangen sozusagen oder schon abdecken. So, und dann gibt es halt eben bei Detrace oder auf dieser Seite gibt es ein IOS-Snoop und das, was macht das nochmal? IOS-Snoop sagt, welches Programm irgendwie auf welche... Wenn das macht ja OpenSnoop scheiße, was macht denn das jetzt? Ich hab's gar nicht so... Ah, da! Execution Live.
Das zeigt halt an, in welche Programme, also in welche Files gerade geschrieben oder gelesen wird.
Und da gibt's halt auf dieser Seite einfach ein paar weitere dieser Tools, mit denen man mal so ein bisschen, wenn eben mal was komisch ist, nachschauen kann. Zum Beispiel eben, wie gesagt, OpenSnoop ist eben der Anwendungsfall. Zum Beispiel, wenn man irgendwie eine Disk nicht ejecten kann, weil irgendein File noch in use ist und man weiß nicht, welche App dieses File use, dann kann man mit OpenSnoop gucken, welche Files werden gerade geused und eben nach diesem File greppen und dann sieht man, welche Prozess das ist und kann den Prozess abschießen und dann gehts weiter. Man kann halt auch für beliebige Programme gucken, was die eben gerade für Syscalls usw. machen und dieser ganze Krempel. Und für Netzwerkverbindungen das gleiche. Also man kann halt auch mit dem D-Trace sozusagen, was macht das sonst? Netzdat oder so? Oder diese Geschichten, welche Programme mit welchen IPs verbunden sind und was die da so für Traffic machen und so, das geht halt eben alles. Oder ein richtig cooles Tool ist noch dieses R-Info. Da scrollen alle Errors quasi durch von allen möglichen Applikationen, die gerade laufen. Und dann sieht man halt z.B. sowas wie permission denied, no such file or directory. Also wenn du dein Firefox startest und der crash gleich wieder, kann man mit R-Info z.B. schauen, ob dieses Firefox-Binary zufällig gerade irgendwelche Errors wirft, die Sinn machen.
Das läuft auch über diesen De-Trace-Mechanismus.
Genau, also all diese Skripte laufen da drüber. Und wie viel Reads und Writes ein Programm auf eine Disk macht. Und einen IOTOP gibt es halt auch prinzipiell, wo man das nochmal sortiert kriegt und so. Also De-Trace super und hier gibt es eine Seite mit fertigen Skripten, wo man mal ein bisschen seinem Rechner wieder auf den Puls fühlen kann.
Die Sache mit dem Latenz-Frei der De-Trace-Probes ist nicht ganz so.
Nicht latenzfrei, aber sehr niedrig.
Wenn ich das richtig verstanden habe, ist das irgendwie so implementiert, dass dort, wo eine Probe sein kann, packen die im Assembler ein paar Nob, also No-Operation-Dinger mit rein. Und wenn du dann die De-Trace-Probe reinklinken willst, werden die überschrieben mit dem Call in die Probe. Und wenn du die Probe nicht mehr brauchst, wird sie wieder rausgenommen, sodass du solange du keine Probes drin hast, tatsächlich auch keine zusätzliche Latenz hast für diese De-Trace-Probes.
Man muss jetzt noch sagen, dass ein NOP der Sender Command für No-Operation ist. Da passiert einfach nix und belegt nur Platz und geht schnell.
Genau, irgendwie so funktioniert es.
Das fanden auch so viele Leute, das hätte ich schon getwittert, und das fanden so viele Leute super. So selten wurde er in Tweets so oft gefavet, ja, wie dieser. Also war voller Erfolg, sag ich mal. Und jetzt vielleicht noch so ein Meta-Thema, ich verschieße einfach gleich mein Pulver am Stück. Auch alles raus. Auch über Hacker-News oder irgendwie über Twitter, ich hab's schon in den Chat gepostet, hat der selbige Paul Graham, der eben auch diese Start-up und Funding macht und eben auch dieses Hacker-News, der hat schon mal bei Y Combinator, ist übrigens auch sehr gut, hat er einen Artikel gepostet, Ideas we'd like to fund. Und wenn ihr danach googelt und auf Position 23 scrollt, steht da zum Beispiel, dass die Wikipedia, so wie sie jetzt ist, die könnte man auch mal deutlich besser machen. Dann wäre so eine Idee, die er gerne funden würde, jemand, der das gleiche Wikipedia antut, was Wikipedia, der Encyclopädie Britannica angetan hat, sozusagen. Im Prinzip so. Und jetzt hat er einen neuen Artikel gepostet, und der heißt Frighteningly Ambitious Startup Ideas. Und da geht's darum unter anderem, und das fand ich Punkt 5, The Next Steve Jobs. Aber der eigentlich interessante Teil war, dass er dann sagt hier, dass er letztens mit einem gesprochen hätte, der Apple sehr gut kennen würde. Und der meinte und hat ihn gefragt, ob denn Apple jetzt ohne Steve noch in der Lage wäre, halt irgendwie coolen Scheiß zu bauen. Und er meint, his answer was simply no. Und meinte eben, dass alles, was jetzt so noch in der Pipeline war und noch von Steve getouched war, sozusagen, und unter seinen perfektionistischen, visionären Griff oder Spirit entstanden ist, dass das jetzt eben alles noch so ein bisschen rausploppt aus der Pipeline, wie das iPad 3, iPhone 5 vielleicht, und danach kommt einfach nur noch Schrott.
Ich frage mich natürlich, welche Person das gewesen sein könnte, die so viel Einblick hat, da gibt es ja nicht so viele.
Ja, da kann man vielleicht zwei Teelöffel Salz nehmen, um diesen Paragraphen da zu vertilgen auf der Hürdenrinde, aber fand ich auf jeden Fall einen netten Zwischensatz dazu.
Apple könnte sich sogar zwei Jahre leisten, Scheiße rauszubringen und es würde wahrscheinlich nichts groß ändern. Eben gerade flog so ein Tweet an mir vorbei. Apple's market value today increased by more than one Nokia.
Das ist jetzt aber nicht die kleinste Bitcoin-Einheit.
Off the charts ist glaube ich die einzige Beschreibung, die man derzeit für Apple so machen kann. Ich fände es ja mal ganz gut, wenn sie auch mal wieder ein bisschen angreifbarer wären. Das war jetzt auch schon fast ein bisschen langweilig.
Ich paste mal den Link, oder ist der schon? Ich paste einfach nochmal hier.
Aber die anderen sind alle so schlecht. Das ist, ich meine, das ist doch wirklich schlimm, dass keiner auch nur im Ansatz denselben Weitblick hat. Ich meine, geh sie ihm nochmal alle durch. Wir haben es hier schon tausendmal besprochen. Ich meine, eigentlich bewahrheitet sich das, was wir jetzt hier schon seit Jahren erzählen. Finde ich in gewisser Hinsicht auch beruhigend. Andererseits beunruhigt mich das auch wieder.
Jetzt, wo wir alle sagen, dass es ohne Steve-Bike abgeht.
Ja, ich meine, die anderen sind irgendwie alle nicht in Form.
Was meinte denn, welche iPhone-Features wir nicht hätten, wenn es kein Android geben würde?
Notifications.
Tethering?
Ich weiß nicht, ob das überhaupt einen hinswerten Einfluss hat.
Was denn?
JavaScript zum Beispiel, liefern die sich ja schon immer noch voll den Krieg.
Ja, aber nicht wegen Android, oder?
Wo hast du denn das jetzt hergeholt?
Welchen Krieg meinst du denn jetzt, dass Google neue Programmiersprachen erfindet, mit denen man JavaScript ersetzen kann?
Die haben doch diesen JavaScript-Engine-Krieg, welcher jetzt irgendwie schneller ist, wo sie sich mal benchmarken.
Was heißt denn Krieg? Ich mein, das ist ja mal ein ganz angenehmer Wettbewerb.
Sag ich aber, der wär halt nicht ohne Google. Nicht ohne Google.
Na Chrome kommt ja jetzt gerade überhaupt erst mal auf Android. Also das hat ja noch gar nicht stattgefunden.
Android 4.0, 1,2% aller Geräte oder so?
Ja, man weiß halt auch nicht, auf wen man sich jetzt überhaupt noch einschießen soll. Früher, als ich meinen Mac bekommen hab, da war es ja eigentlich mit Apple schon fast zu Ende. Da war ich ja voll in der Nische. Aber wir haben es voll gerockt. Wir haben in der Schule die Präsentation über die Geschichte des Flugzeugs gemacht. Wir hatten einen Verlauf mit Zeitstrahl und Fotos von Flugzeugen und haben das ausgedruckt. Das war einfach geil. Wir waren die Chefs, das ist schon eine Grundschule. Ich hab Command & Conquer in SVGA schon gezockt, als die anderen auf dem PC noch in VGA rumgedödelt haben. Und das Photoshop, alles lief schneller. Das war toll, aber wir waren in der Nische. Aber wir hatten auch das klare Feindbild, die PC-User und alles. Und jetzt muss man ja... Wir sind jetzt im Mainstream. Wir sind jetzt voll mittendrin. Vor allen Dingen meine ganzen Verwandten und alle, die haben immer, der John hier mit seinem Mac und so, haben sie alle gelacht. Jetzt kriechen sie auf Wüsten daher, dass ich ihnen mal den Mac erkläre und einrichte.
Greifen wir noch mal eine tankierende Diskussion auf. Wir hatten das Thema ja hier schon ein paar Mal. Noch bevor wir uns ausführlich über Kalenderproblematiken unterhalten haben, hatten wir hier ein anderes killer Thema, nämlich H264. Ihr erinnert euch noch? Googles großartige Ankündigung, H264 sterben zu lassen. Mozilla's ewige Ignoranz. So nach dem Motto, wir blenden euch lieber Flash ein, als ein Industriestandard.
Ist es jetzt nicht unfair, das Thema ohne Max aufzumachen?
Ich habe noch so ein Thema, was unfair ohne Max zu diskutieren wäre.
Ja, das können wir auch gleich noch machen. Ich nenne das jetzt einfach, weil es dran ist. Vielleicht ist Max deshalb auch nicht da. Was ist passiert nach dieser Ankündigung von Google, H264 aus Chrome rauszunehmen?
Wann war die Ankündigung?
Letztes Jahr.
Und ist das auch schon passiert?
Und warum ist das Thema jetzt gerade akut?
Weil Mozilla jetzt, also es kommt jetzt gerade durch. Es gibt da einen Artikel bei Ars Technica, der halt teilweise auch auf Mailing-Listen Beiträge verweist, etc. Und ich glaube auch Äußerungen von Mozilla-Managern, dass die sich jetzt noch mal neu entscheiden und erwägen, ob denn ihre H264-Abstinenz so sinnvoll ist. Im Prinzip gibt es ja für sie drei Optionen. Option 1, das was sie derzeit machen ist, wir setzen das aus, frei muss frei bleiben und wir müssen alles dafür tun, dass nur...
Vogelstrauß in den Sandhaufen mit dem Kopf.
Ja genau, freie Formate. Ich sag das jetzt auch mal wirklich ganz neutral, dass man eben nur freie Formate unterstützt und deswegen darf man jetzt gar nicht anfangen, irgendwas anderes, wo halt Patent und damit eben potenzielle Lizenzzahlungen verbunden sind, dass man das eben macht. Weil in dem Moment, wo man Geld zahlen muss für die Verbreitung von Software, ist sie nicht mehr frei und so weiter. Dem kann ich auch komplett folgen. Das ist für mich vollständig nachvollziehbar. Der Punkt, den ich schwierig fand und der offensichtlich jetzt eben auch als neue Option auftaucht, ist der, wenn eine Plattform von sich aus schon H264 mitbringt und damit natürlich auch alle Lizenzen quasi pauschal abgedeckt hat, dann müssten sie ja immer noch keinen patentbehafteten Code mitführen in ihrem Browser. Sie würden es nur an das Betriebssystem oder an die Plattform anpassen, damit dann eben der Content damit trotzdem abgespielt werden kann. Und dabei handelt es sich nun mal einfach um alle populären Plattformen. Also Android als Target, iOS kommt für sie in dem Sinne gar nicht in Frage. Dann natürlich Windows und Mac OS X, also zumindest das neue Windows, ich glaube seit 7 hat einfach H264 an Bord. Das heißt, es wäre überhaupt gar kein Problem, einen Firefox auszuliefern, der mit HTML5 Audio, Video einfach alles abspielt, was MPEG-4, Audio oder Video ist heute. Oder schon immer. Also das hätten sie auf Mac schon seit, ich weiß nicht, seit wann gibt es H264 auf Mac, wie auch immer. Also es ist einfach alles da und sie müssen nur den Glucode einbauen, das zu machen. Offensichtlich findet diese Debatte jetzt statt und du hast halt diese beiden Lager, die halt zwischen Option 1 und Option 2 machen. Option 3 ist natürlich, wir liefern unseren Firefox mit dem eigenen H264 aus und zahlen dafür. Ich glaube, das wird niemals passieren und das würde ich auch ehrlich gesagt nicht okay finden. Weil ich finde schon, dass in dem Moment, wo es um Patentechnologien geht, die auf einer kommerziellen Plattform zum Einsatz kommen sollen, dass dann eben sehr wohl der Plattform-Provider derjenige ist, der eben diese Kosten auch zu entrichten hat, sodass eben offene Software an der Stelle einfach davon partizipieren kann, aber eben sich selber eigentlich nur um den Glue-Code kümmern muss. In dem Zusammenhang ist es sehr interessant zu sehen, dass Google trotz vollmündiger Ankündigungen mit Web-M und YouTube-Umstellungen etc. und dass sie H264 rausschmeißen wollen, einfach nichts dergleichen getan hat. Ich glaube auch, dass es ein riesen Fehler wäre für sie. Das sehen sie wahrscheinlich mittlerweile auch so, weil es einfach nur dazu führen würde, dass die Leute dann einfach weniger Chrome benutzen.
Das würden sie wahrscheinlich tun, ja.
Genau, und das ist Google natürlich überhaupt nicht recht. Sie sonnen sich gerade darin, stärkster Browser zu werden. Und da sind sie derzeit ja auch auf einem ganz guten Weg. Ja, und das findet jetzt statt.
Aber Mozilla hat gerade was total Cooles released.
Was denn?
Firefox 11 hat einen 3D-Webinspektor. Kannst du hier? Ich dreh das mal für die Timme. Kannst du hier die Demo?
Großartig. Das ist in der Tat wirklich mal eine coole Idee.
Man muss auch mal Mozilla in den Land zerhalten.
So was man noch für Code geben würde. Für Code.
3D-Code. Warum nicht?
Scheiße, ich hab letztens ein voll geiles Video gesehen. Ich muss das besorgen. Das müssen wir in die Show Notes aufnehmen.
Ja, echt wirklich. Du bist also der Meinung, WebM ist jetzt so gut wie tot.
War es jemals am Leben?
WebM war nie live.
War es jemals was anderes als so gut wie tot? Keine Ahnung, kann ich nicht.
Hast du jemals ein WebM-Video gesehen?
Ich hab sogar schon mal nach einem gesucht und keins gefunden.
Aber bei YouTube könntest du ja prinzipiell mit einem Firefox WebM-Videos gucken, wenn du auf HTML5 stellst, oder?
Ja, aber ich hab mal nach WebM Content gesucht. Mit Google. Aber ich hab nichts gefunden. Ich meine, es ist schon schwierig, Okteora-Content zu finden. Aber das ist natürlich in der Wikipedia.
Ich hab's lange nicht mehr projiziert. Jetzt hab ich die HTML5-Trial auf YouTube mal angemacht und suche jetzt mal nach Mobile Macs. Mal sehen, mit Leerzeichen, sonst findet man wahrscheinlich nichts. Das Mobile Mac Lab Fun-Video klick ich jetzt mal an. Und das müsste jetzt ja in WebM kommen, oder? Was? Das was? Ja, ich hab halt, jetzt kommt hier ein Video mit HTML5. Und ich hab im Firefox, der sagt, ich hätte kein H264 hier. Und Show Video Info. Steht natürlich kein Codec, toll. Aber es müsste schon jetzt WebM sein. Es funktioniert tatsächlich, wow.
Na hurra, aber es ist halt nicht erforderlich.
Aber ich hab's, als ich das letzte Mal probiert hab, also als sie das alles so announced hat, und so ein paar Monate später hab ich das auf YouTube probiert, dann ging's nicht. Deswegen ist das jetzt mein erstes WebM-Video, was ich sehe.
Gratuliere.
Kann ich ja noch kurz so ein Video ankündigen, anpreisen?
Wo wir gerade bei Videos sind.
Wenn das fast mit der Diskussion gerade zu tun hat? Nebenbei, also ich seh grad Gruber hat's auch gerade verlinkt. Es gab ja auch diese TV-Show BitTorrent Groups. Also die nennen wir noch mal gleich. Was ist der richtige Sammelname für Release Groups? Die Release Groups haben angekündigt, dass sie jetzt nicht mehr X-Wid und nicht mehr AVI machen, sondern dass jetzt MP4 H264 das Format ist, was hier rauskommt.
Ist das eine Vereinigung der internationalen Illegalen?
Na klar, die Release Groups, so LOL, wie sie alle heißen und so. Das ist doch das, was für andere Leute Sat.1 und Geliathentos ist.
Die haben sich halt auch alle Apple TV gekauft.
Also bisher hauen die alle MKVs raus ohne Ende.
Kannst ja mal pasten hier in die Show Notes noch mit. Achso, da ist schon... Der Chat ist super.
Haben sich ja noch gleich irgendwie welche aufgeregt.
Aber ich mein, über sowas muss man sich erstmal aufregen können. Da gibt's Leute, die machen sich unglaubliche Arbeit, irgendwie Videos ins Netz zu stellen, die sie gar nicht ins Netz stellen dürfen. Andere Leute ziehen die umsonst ab und wollen sich dann aufregen, dass sie nicht im richtigen Format sind.
Aber mein Open Source-Gewissen!
Guck mal, so entstehen Gerüchte da. Und jetzt kann ich nicht mal was dagegen sagen, weil hier mein Link in meiner Zeile wartet. Aber dann kann ich ja jetzt, oder?
Ja, der Chat meint natürlich auch hier, und es wird ja auch im KV benutzt und so weiter. Ja, natürlich, klar, wird alles irgendwie benutzt, aber das ist halt...
Der Nutzen ist schon länger her, ja.
Ist einfach derzeit der Größte in dem Format MP4 H264, weil das ist halt ein Standard, der ist irgendwie definiert und der läuft halt auf allen Geräten auf diesem Planeten.
Naja, das ist halt so eine Sache. Die wollen ja immer hier auch Living Edge, oder wie sagt man, Bleeding Edge benutzen von H264. Und das ist ja nicht das, was Apple unterstützt bisher. Ich weiß nicht, wie sie das jetzt ändern mit 1080p. Vielleicht haben sie ja irgendwie wieder ihre... Doch, die haben da noch was angem. Die unterstützen jetzt ein bisschen mehr, weil es ist nicht vollkommen abwärtskompatibel. Das High Profile?
Das High Profile. Also das 1080p Content, der jetzt bei Apple kommt. Bei Apple, also bei iTunes Filme. Wenn du iTunes Filme in 1080p kaufst, dann ist das H264 High Profile.
Verstehe. Da gibt es ja noch so lauter Parameter, die man auch da so einstellen kann, wo Apple ja nicht bisher alles so...
Genau, das ist wieder ein weiteres Lizenzpaket, was sie da aufgemacht haben. Und dadurch gibt es halt andere Encoder-Optionen und damit natürlich auch Decoder-Optionen. Und damit können sie halt 1080p machen. Also die Files sind gegenüber dem 27p, was noch mit dem... Wie heißt das nochmal, das Profil da drunter? Main? Mit dem Main Profile gemacht wird, sind irgendwie so 10 bis 15% größer, die Dateien. Also wirklich nix. Also da ist halt ne Menge Luft in dem ganzen A264-Standard.
Müssen auch machen, sonst würden die Release Groups glaube ich nicht wechseln werden. Die wüssten, die könnten sonst, wenn sie da immer Bleeding Edge nutzen, noch viel, viel mehr rausholen. Weil es sind ja schon auch so ne Quality-Freaks teilweise. Aber es ist natürlich schick, wenn man irgendwann vielleicht dann wirklich mal keinen VLC oder M-Player braucht, sondern halt das einfach klicken kann und dann irgendwie auch scheiße, ich geh jetzt doch ins Maticore auf meinem iPhone weiter. Das ging halt vorher nicht. Hätte der erste MKV wieder transkoden müssen und so weiter und so fort, das macht ja niemand. Oder du hast halt den Special Player da irgendwie dir auf deinem iPhone installiert, weiß gar nicht, was es da so alles gibt.
Ich hab ja überhaupt gar nichts dagegen, dass auch andere Formate noch entwickelt werden und auch angeboten werden und es wäre auch wirklich cool, wenn halt irgendwie ein ordentliches, freies Format sich parallel noch weiterentwickelt. Aber so diese ganze Verhinderung von AV-Mediendistributionen hat ja, es hat einfach nicht funktioniert. Alles, was Firefox gepusht hat, war Flash. Das ist das einzige, was sie gepusht haben. Alle haben halt einen Flash-Player da noch irgendwie drin. Ich kann an dieser Stelle auch mal noch mal berichten, was manche wahrscheinlich sowieso schon rausgefunden haben. Ich werde da demnächst, sowohl in der nächsten Woche auch noch mal ein größeres Fass aufmachen. Aber die Kurzvariante ist, ich hab halt jetzt von allem, was so audio-mäßig aus der Meta-Ebene kommt, wird jetzt auch in Ogg Audio rausgehauen. Und zwar vor allem erstmal, es gibt keine Feats, zumindest noch nicht. Der Grund war jetzt erstmal, um HTML5 zu ermöglichen mit dem Firefox. Also das ist jetzt alles noch in eine umfangreichere Umstellung. Da gehört noch eine ganze Menge mehr dazu. Das ist wirklich ein riesiger Rattenschwanz, aber I'm slowly getting to the point. Auch so ein bisschen der Grund, warum andere Kanäle gerade so ein bisschen austrocknen. Und ich finde, so eine Multiformatwelt ist an sich nichts Schlechtes, wenn man sie sich leisten kann. Aber es ist gut, dass es zumindest einen Industriestandard gibt, auf dem man sich irgendwie erstmal einigt, dass man den auf jeden Fall immer überall immer kann. Und dann können die anderen sich bemühen, auch toll zu sein. Freier oder besser oder am besten alles auf einmal. Gibt es auch ein gutes Beispiel in dem Zusammenhang, wenn man nämlich jetzt mal nur Audio macht. Und zwar gibt es da ein interessantes Developer-Talk-Video. Ich muss jetzt gerade nochmal kurz die URL zu raussuchen. Und zwar gibt es einen neuen Open Source-Audio-Codec, der wirklich sehr interessant ist. Und zwar heißt der Opus. Schon mal gehört? Da gibt es einen schönen Vortrag von Jean-Marc Valin auf YouTube Opus The Smith Army Knife of Audio-Codecs, wo er diesen Codec vorstellt. Und das ist in dem Sinne auch überhaupt nichts Neues. Sondern das ist eine Weiterentwicklung von zwei Codecs. Einerseits Silk von Skype und dem Zelt-Codec, der als Low-Latency-Codec ist.
Ich glaube, das habe ich auch schon lesen vor einer Weile.
Und das sind halt zwei Low-Latency-Codecs. Und der Clou bei Opus ist, dass sie den weiterentwickelt haben.
Das ist aber dein Sprachcodec, kein Audiocodec.
Ja, pass auf, also Silk ist optimiert für Low-Bandwidths und nur für Sprache. Und der Zelt wiederum war auch für Sprache gedacht, aber eben für höhere Bitraten auch geeignet. Und die basierten auf so ein bisschen unterschiedlichen Herangehensweisen. Und für Opus haben sie da jetzt quasi beide in eine Wachschale geworfen, haben sich ein neues Bitstream-Format ausgedacht. Was es erlaubt, erstens mitten im Audio-Stream die Bitrate zu ändern, aber auch den Codec umzuschalten, als auch die Framegröße umzuschalten. Das Ding kann irgendwie 20ms Frames machen und kann runtergehen bis auf 2ms, weiß nicht mehr ganz genau. Hier war was sehr kleines, also für Low-Latency geeignet, für niedrige Bitströme. Und während sie aber den so weiterentwickelt haben und die neuesten Audio-Encoding-Ideen da eingesetzt haben, die interessanterweise nicht mehr wie das MP3 und MP4 machen, so mit diesem Ausblenden von Sachen, die du nicht hörst, arbeiten, sondern auf einem ganz anderen Prinzip basieren, ist Opus jetzt, eigene Darstellung, ich hab's jetzt nicht gegen gehört, qualitativ mit AAC und auch mit HE AAC auf einer Höhe. Besser als Forbes und in den niedrigen Betraten halt ohnehin weitgehend konkurrenzlos. Sehr interessantes Projekt, kann ich jedem nur empfehlen, sich mal diesen Vortrag anzuschauen, weil er auch sehr interessante Einblicke liefert, wie sie da halt arbeiten. Also die teilen das irgendwie so in Bänder auf, die sie auch noch dynamisch irgendwie anpassen können.
Ja, die singen nur, dass normalerweise Sprachkodex und Audiokodex eine komplett andere Herangehensweise haben. Weil Audiokodex ja danach gehen, was kannst du hören und was kannst du nicht hören. Stichwort Verdeckungseffekt. Und Sprachkodex aber danach gehen, wie entsteht Sprache beim Sprechen im Mund.
Ja und hier ist es halt nicht so, sondern hier machen sie weder das eine noch das andere. Sondern was sie machen ist, jetzt bin ich, hab den Vortrag nur einmal gesehen, reden sie von einem, wie hat das genannt, Energielevel pro Band. Also was sie ausdrücken ist eine Energie eines Bandes. Und das ist das, was sie kodieren. Und sie meint, er sagt das in diesem Vortrag, dass einfach dieses Ganze mit Ausblenden, welche Frequenz man hört oder so, findet in diesem Kodec einfach nicht statt. Es ist einfach kein psycho-akustisches Modell whatsoever irgendwie hier drin. Das ist spannend. Sie haben sich hier einfach auf einen ganz anderen Ansatz eingeschworen und sind mit den Ergebnissen extrem zufrieden. Und das Ding ist jetzt weitgehend fertig, ist ein IETF-Standard, ist kurz vor dem Last Call und könnte demnächst das Licht der Welt erblicken. Sehr interessantes Projekt.
Also ist dann auch für Audio, Telefonieren, aber auch für Musik geeignet.
Genau, und aber auch für interaktiv. Also für sehr schnelle Turnarounds, so Direktional, Low Latency, bis hin zu Musik. Sie meinen, Sie decken alles ab und das Einzige, was Sie nicht abdecken, ist das, was flack abdeckt. Also da wär's dann Quatsch, Opus zu verwenden, aber alles so bis 128, 256 Kilobits.
Naja, ich meine, lossy Codec ist ein lossy Codex und lossless Codec ist ein lossless Codec.
Ja, aber jetzt so von der Anwendung her gesprochen.
Naja, hätte ja auch sein können, dass der halt so coole Algorithmen hat, dass er auch lossless-mäßig irgendwie besser ist, als das, was es schon gibt. Wieso nicht? Gibt's ja auch. Irgendwann wird natürlich auch ein besserer lossless Codec kommen.
Naja, schaut's euch an, opuscodec.org. Sehr interessantes Projekt. 2,5 Millisekunden bis 60 Millisekunden. Da steht's ja, genau.
Erstmal klonen, dann schauen wir mal.
Genau, Bitraten bis 510 Kilobits pro Sekunde, sagen sie. Ach so, ja, genau. Sampling-Rates vom 8 bis 48 Kilohertz. Sie meinten auch, das wär auch irgendwie bei Ihnen, das hab ich nicht so ganz verstanden, aber im Kern, die Kernaussage war, so was wie Sampling-Rate gibt's bei Ihnen eigentlich gar nicht. Also es ist egal, was du da reinschiebst, eh alles, können wir von 48 zu 44, 1 jederzeit, beliebig hin und her umstellen. Und Floating-Point-Implementierung und Fix-Point-Implementierung. Also das ist irgendwie alles sehr interessant, finde ich. So, genau, jetzt merkt auch gerade noch jemand an, dass ich auch noch die Bitraten runtergeschraubt habe bei meinen Podcasts. Ja, das ist auch alles noch nicht fertig. Das ist alles gerade noch so im Entstehen. Aber grundsätzlich verwende ich jetzt einfach bessere Encoder-Strecken und da wird gerade viel geforscht. Und ich denke, dass ich dieselbe Qualität auch mit der Hälfte der Daten, die ich verbrate, rüberbringen kann. Sodass ich nicht immer irgendwie 25 Terabyte im Monat durch die Weltgeschichte schicken muss.
25 Terabyte?
Ja, das ist ein High-Volume-Business hier. Krasse Reihe.
Kann ich jetzt mein Video mal ankündigen?
Ja, bitte.
Ankündigen.
Na ja, wie soll man sagen? Halt letztens, hat mir jemand gezeigt, war ganz cool. Und zwar ich poste mal hier so, tschak, da ist es.
Aus der beliebten Kategorie hat mir jemand gezeigt, war ich ganz cool.
Genau, der heißt Brett Victor, wo er war, mal auch bei Apple, irgendwie für LG User Interface, Konzepte verantwortlich und so weiter, jada, jada. Aber es ist auch ein bisschen länglich, das Video, 54 Minuten. Und zwar zeigt der dort, wie er ein Spiel programmiert und das Spiel dann auch mittendrin live anhält und Parameter live setzt, die dann auch gleich sofort im Spiel ohne neu starten, ohne alles irgendwie zu sehen sind. Also es ist alles, ich glaube, das gibt es nicht als Produkt oder sonstiges, sondern es ist alles so ein bisschen so, wie nennt man das, prototypenmäßig oder hingebastelt für diesen Vortrag. Aber so stellt er sich sozusagen die Zukunft des Programmierens vor. Und das ist halt nicht nur Programmieren, sondern er zeigt auch zum Beispiel wieder eine Schaltung ist, wo zwei LEDs sind, die abwechselnd so blinken und dass er dann halt irgendwelche Widerstände oder sonstige anpasst und du immer gleich live die Werte siehst. Also er will, dass alles, was man produktiv irgendwie mit irgendeinem Programm macht, gleich das, was man ändert, auch live sofort irgendwie, dass einem das Programm entgegenkommt und gleich sagt, was dann passieren würde. Also der zeigt zum Beispiel beim Programmieren, das ist so bei Minute 10 oder so, kannst ja mal vielleicht hinspringen, wenn das klappt da, damit ihr schon mal so ein Bild habt. Da zeigt er, er will einen Binary Search programmieren und tippt so den Code los und rechts steht immer da, dass wenn folgende Werte drin wären, das gibt er dann halt schon so vor in seinem Test, dass dann Folgendes passieren würde, während er den Code schreibt. Also dann schreibt er so und kann dann mal gleich sehen, was passiert und wann es falsch ist. Und wenn er eine Schleife macht, dann kannst du alle einzelnen Schritte der Schleife sehen und welche Werte in deinen Variablen wären, um gleich so zu zeigen, alles klar, hier ist irgendwie folgender Fehler. Also er visualisiert halt irgendwie eine Menge. Und das aber auch, wie gesagt, mit dieser Schaltung, wo die LEDs blinken, wo er dann irgendwie sich natürlich, weiß nicht, lässt er sich live natürlich auch die Voltage anzeigen und Zeug und so. Und all sowas. Und er hätte das gerne, also er geht sehr grundsätzlich ran, hätte das auch gerne für alle möglichen anderen Sachen. Also es geht gar nicht nur um Programmieren oder so, sondern auch um ja alles. Ich glaube ein Audiobespiel hat er auch irgendwie dabei gehabt. Und ich fand's interessant, weil es sah, die Examples, die er da hat, so das sind richtig live Programme. Ich weiß nicht, was der da gekodet hat oder wie er das zusammengestellt hat, dass es alles so echt aussieht, ob es die für ihn vielleicht wirklich schon gibt. Aber das fand ich als Präsentation echt nicht schlecht, was er da schon so am Start hat. Genau, da ist er am Zeichnen und...
Be-be.
Mi-mi-mi-mi-mi.
Also könnt ihr euch mal angucken. Und das ist auf jeden Fall ziemlich cool.
Mi-mi-mi-mi-mobile-mix.
Mi-mi-mi-mobile-mix.
Interessant.
Ja, müsst euch mal gucken. Ist wirklich cool.
Videos auf Vimeo sind irgendwie auch viel schöner. Ich weiß nicht wieso, auch wenn es gar nicht so schön aussieht, aber irgendwie...
Because they don't take everything. Wenn du da einen Screencast hochlädst, dann löschen sie dir den.
Wie?
Ja, bei YouTube kannst du halt alles hochladen, wenn es kein Porn ist, oder keine Ahnung, oder kein Porn. Und bei Vimeo sagen sie halt, das ist halt eine Videoplattform.
Ja, aber sie lassen Screencast, also sie nehmen nicht alles, aber Screencast habe ich selber schon hochgeladen.
Aber nicht so mitgeschnittene, ne, habe ich Screencast gesagt? Ich meinte hier so Spiele-Mitschnitte, so Gaming. Was nennt man denn das, wenn man so einen Game-Durchlauf mitschneidet?
Speedrun.
Ja, nee, aber es ist schön, da gibt es schöne Sachen auf Vimeo.
Soll ich mal wieder ein Thema einbringen?
Bitte.
Erstmal Hardware. Also ich hab da so einen Server zu Hause mit FreeBSD. Da sind sechs Platten drin. Ja natürlich.
Fett, der Rhyme ist fett, man!
Mir ging es jetzt nicht um das ZFS, sondern mir ging es darum, das Netzteil, was da drin war. Da war da ein 350 Watt Netzteil drin. Das ist eigentlich ausreichend. Aber wenn man die Kiste anmacht und alle Platten gleichzeitig anfangen, hoch zu laufen, geht das Netzteil manchmal nicht.
Hast du von Delayed Spin-Up gehört?
Ja, weiß ich nicht, wie man so was einstellt.
Gibt es einen Jumper, den setze ich da irgendwo. Ja, und dann fahren die so nacheinander hoch.
Auf welcher Platte musst du den Jumper setzen, damit alle nacheinander hochfahren?
Auf allen.
Naja, wie auch immer.
Ja, oder im BIOS vielleicht noch irgendwo einstellen. Aber bei den SCSI-Platten von IBM gab es einen Delayed Spin-Up. Oder die fahren gar nicht hoch, solange das BIOS nicht sagt, fahr mal hoch.
SCSI-Platten von IBM?
Ist schon eine Weile her, aber es gibt auf jeden Fall so etwas wie Delayed Spin-Up. Dann gibt es das inzwischen halt im BIOS, in der SATA-Controller.
Wie dem auch sei. Ich hatte da immer wieder das Problem, dass der halt manchmal beim Anschalten nicht hoch kam oder manchmal sogar seine BIOS-Einstellungen vergessen hat, weil das Netzteil genau an der Stelle halt in die Knie gegangen ist. Also habe ich mir überlegt, naja, baust du halt ein dickeres Netzteil rein. Habe ich jetzt statt einem 350 Watt Netzteil einen 750 Watt Netzteil reingebaut. Naja, eigentlich habe ich das nur gekauft, weil da waren so viele SATA-Stromstecker dran, wie ich gebraucht habe. Und ja, das hat irgendwie nur 40 Euro gekostet und für 6 Euro weniger wären da nur irgendwie zwei dran gewesen und dann hätte ich lauter Adapter noch mit dazu gebraucht und so und das ist also alles.
Und vor allem die verbrauchen ja nicht 700 Watt die ganze Zeit.
Und jetzt ist nämlich das Ding, ich habe den Rechner vorher ans Stromnetzgerät gehängt, also an Strom, Netz, Mess, wie auch immer, gehangen.
Du hast den Stromverbrauch gemessen auf Deutsch.
Ich habe den Stromverbrauch gemessen und zwar damit es fair ist. Jetzt kommt das ZFS wieder, habe ich einen Scrub angeworfen, damit die Platten ordentlich was zu tun haben.
Was war noch mal das Scrub?
Checken, ob die Checksummen stimmen und entsprechend korrigieren, wenn man einen Raid oder so hat. Also alle Platten im Betrieb hat das Ding 78 Watt gebraucht.
Da holst du so einen riesen Netzteil für.
Du, keine Ahnung, ich hatte halt immer Probleme mit dem Netzteil. So, jetzt habe ich das Netzteil getauscht, habe das wiedergemacht, habe wieder gemessen und jetzt könnt ihr mal raten, wie viel Strom der hinterher verbraucht hat.
Kommt drauf an, was das für ein Netzteil war. Wenn du vorher so einen Ramsch-Netzteil hattest, was irgendwie voll hoher Eigenverbrauch hat oder weißt schon, also einen schlechten Wirkungsgrad, so heißt das, dann kann es schon sein, dass es jetzt mit dem neuen viel geringer ist, weil du wahrscheinlich irgendwie ein moderneres Netzteil hast. Wobei man aber auch sagt, dass man ein Netzteil irgendwie so mehr in Richtung 90 Prozent auslassen soll, weil es in dem Bereich den besten Wirkungsgrad hat. Das heißt, da du jetzt mit deinem prozentualen Anteil voll daneben liegst, müsste es eigentlich ziemlich schlecht sein, da es aber gleichzeitig ein modernes Netzteil ist. Könnte ich sagen, weil du uns ja auch zu überraschend willst, ich sage weniger Verbrauch als vorher.
Nee, weniger nicht, aber genauso viel. Das war genau der gleiche.
Deswegen erzählst du uns das jetzt alles? Dann lag ich ja richtig, das ist neu Verbrauch, deswegen weniger. Gleichzeitig bist du im falschen Prozentbereich von dem neuen Netzteil und deswegen gleicht es dir wieder aus, plus minus null, zack.
Nee, ich fand das nur so merkwürdig, weil man liest halt überall, baue kein zu dickes Netzteil an, ein, das verbraucht einfach viel zu viel Strom und dann mache ich das halt notgedrungen und Stromverbrauch ist A, genau der gleiche.
Ja, wie gesagt, die modernen Netzteile sind ja voll mit Gold-Dingens oder was haben die, Platin-Standard und so, mit Wirkungsgrad 80, 85, 90 Prozent und so und das wird dann ein altes Ding wahrscheinlich nicht gehabt haben.
Weißt der Ehrenwerte Herr Dennis seine Zeichen, Bitcoin-Miners zu berichten?
Ja, ich hab zu Hause, ich hab ein 1200 Watt Netzteil und...
1200 Watt?
Naja, wo gehobelt wird, fallen Bitcoins, ne?
Auf jeden Fall. Und da war ich auch sehr dafür, dass es halt auch eins mit Gold-Standard++ ist, weil da will man, dass der Wirkungsgrad stimmt, weil ich will ja keine Watt verschwenden. Lieber dann mal 10 Euro mehr bezahlt fürs Netzteil, kostet über 200 Euro so ein Teil.
Gold-Standard++, das fände ich gut. Gibt's halt.
Ja, wollte ich noch mal berichten, dass das nicht so ein entscheidender Faktor zu sein scheint.
Ja, aber mal ganz ehrlich, wenn du wirklich da in Richtung 80 Watt verbrauchst und davon 750 Watt Netzteil nimmst, ist das schon ein bisschen bekloppt. Also irgendwas muss da beim Starten des Rechners ganz schön schief laufen, dass es dann da gleich so zusammen bricht. Wahrscheinlich liegt es eher, dass das alte Netz dann nicht mehr ganz so taufrisch war und du einfach ein neues 350er hättest holen müssen. Oder vielleicht sogar nur 200 oder so. Aber jetzt hast du ja eins, ne? Und was weiß.
Das tut ja jetzt.
Kannst du ein paar Grafikkarten reinstecken auf jeden Fall.
Ich weiß, das ist jetzt ein bisschen blöde Firmennahmäßig, aber was?
Nee, das ist so ein Atomboard und da ist nur ein Steckplatz drin und da steckt schon eine SATA-Karte.
Was hast du? Was ist das für ein Netzteil?
Hab ich das hier? Nee, das hab ich jetzt hier. Ich müsste dich kurz wühlen, dann kann ich es dir sagen. Aber das ist jetzt...
So ein bekannter Name oder so ein Be Quiet, Cooler Master oder wie heißen die alle da? Diese kanadische Firma gibt es auch noch. Man soll ja mal gleich ganz viele Firmen nennen, wenn man schon Schleichwerbung macht. So war es doch. Wenn der eine Langnese sagt, muss der andere Schlecker sagen oder wie war das? Wie heißt der andere heiß?
By the way, wo wir gerade hier bei Assorted Topics sind, heute twitterte mir jemand zu.
Ein Vögelchen hat die gezwitschert.
Ein Vögelchen hat mir einen gezwitschert. Das die Telekom ab, das war's jetzt.
IPv6 macht noch dieses Jahr.
Geht's dir gut, wieder nix.
Wo ist denn nochmal gleich hier der Tweet? Moment, mir ist der Tweet entfleucht. Dass die Telekom VDSL 100 anbieten wird als Upgrade für das, was man jetzt schon mit VDSL 50 hat. In Mai, Juni für 5 Euro extra.
Gleich bestellen für den Club.
Und zwar 100 down, 25 ab.
Wenn das stimmt.
Bist du dabei?
Ich gemachte man. Ja, ich weiß vor allem, dass mein Anschluss 100 kann.
Woher? Weil der Kasten vor der Tür steht?
Erstens das und zweitens, weil ich ja jetzt hier Internet über die Fritzbox betreibe, immer noch mit einem lachenden oder weinenden Auge. Und ein Feature dieser Fritzbox ist, dass sie einem ja auch wirklich die Leitung ausmisst und sagt, was ginge. Siehe auch CAE 191 zu einer ausführlichen Diskussion dieses Themas.
Die sind halt so in ordentlichem Modell gemacht, ne?
Genau. Und also 25 würde ich wahrscheinlich nicht erreichen, aber 22. Das würde mir allerdings auch schon erst mal reichen.
Aber kriegst du das dann auch von der Telekom? Also ich zu Hause hab ja auch Telekom, hatte VOR alles und die haben mich erst mal von 16 auf 13 runtergestuft.
Wie, was, wie, was, ob ich was von der Telekom bekomme?
Na oft nur die 25 oder wie du sagst, dann sowieso physikalisch, wenn du Fritz Bock sagst, dass es dann noch 22 durchgehen würden. Die Telekom ist ja dann mal ein bisschen konservativ und kriegst am Ende nur 15 oder so.
Die kriegen dann einfach The Mother of all Einlauf. Da kannst du ja mal Stein und Bein draufschwören, dass die so lange trieze und...
Bis die das dann mal machen. Ich sehe schon, hier geht wieder nichts in der Station, weil Tim unbedingt fast Speed haben wollte und deswegen...
Ja, mein D-Slam brummt hier wirklich direkt gegenüber. Also das hier irgendwie keine 20 Meter entfernt.
Und dann kriegst du schon keine 25, sondern nur 22.
Ja gut, keine Ahnung, was die jetzt für Technik haben und wie viele Ecken die Kabel noch vorher nehmen.
Ich hab schon von Leuten gehört, die kein DSL kriegen, weil der Kasten auf der anderen Straßenseite ist und der andere Straßenblock hat halt ganz andere Kabel ganz woanders hingelegt. Also das heißt gar nicht, wenn der Kasten auf der anderen Seite ist.
Ja, das mag auch sein, dass das gar nicht derjenige ist. Aber immerhin weiß ich schon mal, dass ich zumindest hunderttauglich bin grundsätzlich. Und vielleicht ist das auch dann an der Stelle nur noch mal so ein Modem-Trim-Option, dass sie da noch mal irgendwas drehen müssen und dann spuckt er auch 25 aus. Das könnte durchaus sein, dass sie da einfach eine Profiländerung vornehmen und dann würde auch das gehen.
Mir fällt auch ein, dass ich bei meinem Special ISP-Checker noch mal sagen muss, dass ich ins IPv6-Beta-Programm will. Weil es gibt jetzt schon IPv6 da. Naja, aber es ist noch nicht für alles. Nur ist jetzt immer noch so Testphase, aber ich kann mir schon da reinschreiben lassen.
Von der Telekom?
Nee, von der deutschen Kabel-Gesellschaft.
Ja, ich hab mir jetzt hier auch mal richtiges V6 geklickt über einen Dienst, den ich so vorher auch noch nicht kannte. Das geht nämlich auch, wenn man eine Fritz-Box hat. Da geht ja so einiges, wie ich feststellen muss. Was für dir ein Six-Tunnel?
Also das ist... Dieser Six-Doppel...
Also sixxs.net. Da, wenn man also eine Fritz-Box hat und man will mal ein ordentliches IPv6 haben, dann klickt man sich da in den Account. Das ist eine ganz nerdige Webseite und denen geht es halt einfach darum, IPv6-Usage nach oben zu treiben. Da klickt man sich dann irgendwie in den Account. Dann kriegt man so Punkte dafür, dass man das hat. Und das Lustige ist, man muss halt immer... Man kann sich dann auch so verschiedene Features klicken, weitere Tunnel dazu, etc. Aber um weitere Features zu bekommen, musst du eben genug Punkte haben. Und die Punkte bekommst du halt erst mal beim Sign-Up. Danach zahlst du quasi für deine eingerichteten Tunnel in diesen Punkten. Aber wenn du dann diese Tunnel auch tatsächlich betreibst, also benutzt und nicht nur klickst und verbrauchst, dann kriegst du halt noch mehr Punkte, um dir eben da noch mehr holen zu können. Du kannst ja dann halt Tunnel aufbauen. Das hab ich jetzt hier sozusagen für alle meine DSLs gemacht. Direkt von der Fritzbox aus. Und damit hat man halt dann auch sein eigenes Slash64-Netzwerk, etc. Und es gibt dann auch noch so ein Tool, was man sich das theoretisch auch noch auf den Laptop drauf machen kann. Irgendwie dieses AICCU. Da kann man sich dann den Tunnel dann auch noch mal dynamisch auf seinem Laptop auch noch machen lassen. Und wenn man halt irgendwo ist, wo mal wieder schwerer der Netz ist und man will nach Hause telefonieren, dann kann man halt sich jetzt einfach richtige IPv6-Connectivity machen und man kann direkt die Adressen der eigenen Computer ansprechen über IPv6 und kann nach Hause telefonieren ohne irgendwelchen Mumpitz.
Genau, wenn die Leute dann die Firewall vergessen auf IPv6 zu stellen, dann kommt es doch immer direkt durch.
Ja, es wird jetzt auch so, ich habe ja schon so das Gefühl, dass es 2012 noch was werden könnte mit diesem IPv6.
Das drängt jetzt halt auch.
Irgendwie ist doch da im Juni auch so diese IPv6-Launch-Day, wo auch dieses Jahr tatsächlich so schon ein paar große Telcos aus Usa sich, glaube ich, committed haben. Als ich das ja den Kabel Deutschland-Spezialkontakten erzählt habe, haben die gleich darüber nachgedacht, Urlaub zu buchen. Also ob das bei Kabel Deutschland beziehungsweise in Deutschland generell dieses Jahr schon zu IPv6 für alle kommt, das darf noch bezweifelt werden. Aber es kommt näher, es rollt unaufhällsam auf uns zu. Ich meine, eigentlich ist ja schon alles bereit.
Eigentlich ist das Thema aus der Tür.
Zum Beispiel beim DFN hier an der Uni, da habe ich mir jetzt auch im Medienhaus der UDK einfach auch mal IPv6 geben lassen von dem DFN. Und die haben das schon ewig. Die haben ja auch da schon so Testnetz, schon seit Ewigkeiten, das funktioniert auch alles problemfrei.
Alle haben IPv6 schon seit Ewigkeiten, nur beim Endkunden kommt es irgendwie nicht richtig an. Ich hätte ja gerne auch, dass es aus meinem PPPoE rausfällt, irgendwie einfach so plopp macht und da ist.
Eigentlich willst du doch gar kein PPPoE haben, sondern dass es einfach nur rausfällt.
Hauptsache es fällt raus.
Na, schön wäre das.
Also mit diesem 6x macht man sich dann quasi ein IPv6-Tunnel durch ein IPv4 über PPPoE.
PPPoE kommt da jetzt so explizit nicht nochmal zum Einsatz meines Wissens.
Na ja, gut, aber dein TSL macht ja.
Ja gut, wo auch immer dein IPv4 herkommt, darüber machst du das in deinem Tunnel.
Du kannst halt auch, wenn dein Modem das kann, kannst du das auch konfigurieren, dass es dir einen 624-Tunnel macht und dann musst du gar nichts konfigurieren und gar nichts weiter dir konfigurieren, sondern dann funktioniert das einfach so tatsächlich.
Ja, aber du hast halt dann bei jedem Dial-App auch wieder eine andere Adresse und das ist halt das Problem mit dem 6SS.
6SS.
Hast du halt deine eigenen Netze. So, du kannst richtig anfangen, dir deine eigene IPv6 Infrastruktur zusammenzupfen.
Und du kannst sogar einen Reverse-Lookup dir dafür eintragen lassen. Also du kannst dann auch deine eigenen Host-Names da erscheinen lassen und so weiter. Und das ist auch kostenlos mit dem Reverse-Lookup. Hab ich auch schon alles gemacht. Aber wenn es dir halt darum geht, jetzt erstmal nur IPv6 zu haben, dann kannst du auch zum Beispiel bei den Airport Extreme und so auch 6to4 einschalten. Und dann macht er das. Ich glaube, es macht sogar, wenn die Airport Extreme direkt am DSL hängt, quasi direkt am Modem, dann macht die 6to4 automatisch.
War das eine Default-Einstellung?
Ich glaube, ich glaube, so war das. Also wenn du es nochmal, wenn du den nur so als WLAN-Router betreibst und irgendwo so hinten in deinem Netz betreibst, dann macht das halt nicht. Aber wenn es direkt sozusagen das DSL-Modem am Warnport hängt, dann macht das 6to4 automatisch an, glaube ich. Wenn es sozusagen die AirPod Extreme aber nur über den LAN-Port anschlägt, dann schlägt er nicht mit der Netzinfrastruktur. Und das war doch mal die News, dass diese Apple-Geräte jetzt zu einem signifikanten Teil zur IPv6, also von 0,3 auf 0,4 Prozent oder so beitragen, weil die einfach automatisch dann am Warn-Port diese 6to4 einschalten.
Der größte Sprung war ja irgendein französischer Provider, der irgendwie schon vor zwei Jahren einfach zack eingeschaltet hat und dann ging es irgendwie fett nach oben.
Ja und man muss auch sagen, so bei BitTorrent, wenn man dann so seine Wikipedia und OpenStreetMap-Dumps runterlädt, man sieht jetzt auch immer mehr IPv6-Adressen. Also es ist, sagen wir mal, so gefühlt, so dass jetzt schon immer so 5 bis 6 Prozent sogar, die man da sieht. Dank Erdgeist. Also es verbreitet sich tatsächlich weiter.
Und selbst weil die World of Warcraft ist schon IPv6-tauglich jetzt, die wissen genau Zahlen, die Kunden will man nicht verlieren, schnell mal IPv6 eingebaut. Die waren auch schnell auf 64-Bit, die waren voll schnell auf Intel, also da wo die Kohle fließt, sind die immer ganz flott dabei.
Ja, aber das ist ja das Ding, dass eigentlich bei IPv6 ja bisher noch keine Kohle fließt, deswegen ist ja noch keiner für nötig halt hielt, da mal was zu machen. Aber jetzt so langsam, jetzt wo die IPv4-Adressen alle sind.
Nee, die sind alle.
Also kriegst keine mehr, aber.
Haben sie den letzten Block ausgeben, haben wir jeweils einen so einen riesen, was war das, einen riesen B-Netz an jeden Nick weltweit, an jeden Kontinent?
Also theoretisch ist da wohl schon noch irgendwie, wenn man jetzt müsste, irgendwas zu holen, aber so offiziell ist der Pool erstmal ausgeschöpft.
Da gab's doch irgendwie letztens hab ich mal, oder was heißt letztens, irgendwie vor einer Weile hab ich mal geguckt, was so die amerikanischen Unis, wie groß der Netzblöcke sind und so, davon so Apple und so, das war ja auch irgendwie immer ganz schön beeindruckend, was die so für Riesennetze haben, wobei wenn man jetzt hier geht sogar.
Ja, Apple hat sich halt immer an Klaas Ahn jetzt geklickt am Anfang.
Ja, sollten so machen, gab's nicht kleiner, ne? Das hat schon seinen Grund, warum Apple die 17 hat, als IP, und zwar alles mit 17.
MIT hat alles mit 18, Berkeley, wie war das?
Das heißt, hier war noch noch ein vor dem MIT da.
Tatsächlich.
Ist echt erstaunlich, oder?
Was hat denn, wie wird denn Berkeley geschrieben?
E-Y-Berkeley.
Aber dabei hat ja Apple mit Internet, ich meine, bis wann haben die das eigentlich selbst mal in ihren Geräten so?
Hat gedauert.
Hat schon gedauert, weil sie mit dem Apple Talk eigentlich ja auch ganz andere Netzkram gemacht haben.
Na ja, sagen wir mal so, es hat lang gedauert, bis sie das so hatten, dass man da richtig froh drüber sein konnte. Mit Mac OS X war dann eigentlich das erste Mal alles wirklich okay.
Also dieses Open Transport war schon eigentlich eine ganz gute Geschichte.
Ja, das stimmt, da ist es auch schon...
Da ging es langsam.
Das hätte das, genau, das war eigentlich der erste Mal so Mac TCP Zeit.
Ja, das war Gott sei Dank, als ich zum Mac kam, das war ja so Anfang 96, da war, glaub, da kam Open Transport gerade frisch raus.
Was war das, 7.6?
Ne, 7.5.1 oder so.
Ne.
Doch.
Ich hab noch 7.5.1. Das war das Update, wo die Alkons so leicht transparent wurden, wenn du sie genommen hast. Das Update war das.
Kann ich mich noch genau erinnern.
Tatsächlich 7.5.2.
Ja oder so. 7.5.3 gab's glaub ich auch noch.
Jaja und 7.5.3 Release. Ne, 7.5.3 V2 Release, da gab's so eine völlig absurde MacOS-Version.
Kann sein.
Und eine, die kam gar nicht raus. Die haben sie dann irgendwie übersprungen und dann waren sie bei 5.5, 7.5.5 glaub ich, ne? Das waren die dunkelsten Zeiten überhaupt.
Das war das Schlimmste. Als ich die Versionsnummer gesehen habe, wusste ich, dass sie am Arsch sind. Dass die Zeit gezählt ist. Ich guck grad mal, wie die hieß. Da gibt's hier bestimmt einen Wikipedia-Eintrag dazu. Na los, her damit. 7, 5, genau. 7, 5, 3, Revision 2 und dann kam eine Revision 2.1 raus und noch eine Revision 2.2. 7, 5, 3, Revision 2.2. Da blutete das wirklich aus den Ohren in diesem Laden.
Ja, aber das war der Punkt, wo sie dachten, sie bringen jetzt das neue, wie hätte das geheißen? Demen hieß es raus und haben überhaupt nichts mehr an System 7 gemacht, aber Copland war ja irgendwie noch in the cloud.
Das war furchtbar.
So, sind uns die Themen jetzt offiziell ausgegangen?
Na, ich guck nochmal.
Hat der Chat noch irgendwas beizutragen? Jetzt schon. Waren wir artig? Ich finde, wir müssen nicht immer so überlange Sendungen machen.
Ich hab höchstens noch ein paar Fragen, von denen ich gerne wüsste, ob ihr da eine Antwort habt.
Du hast Fragen an uns.
Ja, genau. Das erste ist in Mail. Wenn man da Verlauf anschaltet.
Verlauf. Jetzt mussten wir erstmal sagen, wie das auf Englisch heißt. Ich benutze meinen Computer auf Englisch.
Der Mail-Gradient.
Na, jetzt hängt das ganz. Nee, das ist, wenn...
Du meinst, ein Konversationsmodus.
Ja, genau, diesen Konversationsmodus. Dann, wenn man aus dieser Konversation einzelne Mails löscht bzw. wenn man Mails gelöscht hat und er ist der Meinung, eine neu reingekommene Mail gehörte zu einer Konversation, wo auch gelöschte Mails dazu gehören, dann zeigt er mir in der Konversation immer alle Mails an, einschließlich derer, die im Papierkorb liegen. Und ich frage mich, kann man das irgendwie ausschalten?
Na ja, du kannst den Papierkorb halt löschen. Das ist halt der Sinn eines Papierkorbs, dass das noch nicht richtig weg ist, sondern nur als gelöscht markiert. Und dann ist es ja auch sinnvoll, dass du auch Dinge findest, die im Trash sind. Wenn du jetzt zu Hause durch deine Wohnung rennst und so einen wichtigen Zettel suchst und der liegt nur im Papierkorb, dann willst du den ja auch finden.
Ja, schon, aber weißt du, wenn ich meine Aktenordner aus dem Regal ziehe und gucke so, ja, was ist denn da so gewesen? Und dann sind dahinter plötzlich noch so drei zerknüllte Zettel, die schon im Papierkorb waren. Also ich meine...
Leerst du deinen Papierkorb nicht?
Ja, scheinbar nicht oft genug. Ich weiß es nicht. Also irgendwie, das ist so was, wo ich so...
Das ist eine kurze Umfrage hier, ja. Wie oft leert ihr euren Papierkorb? Immer wenn er voll ist eigentlich? Also immer, immer?
Also den normalen Papierkorb schon, aber den von Mail leere ich gar nicht.
Ach so, den normalen. Also meinst du schon auch den digitalen normalen, nicht den, der im Raum steht?
Nein, den leert man nicht so oft.
Ich habe irgendwie auch noch so von, also ich weiß nicht, wahrscheinlich mache ich auch schon zu lange mit Computern. Ich schließe immer alle Programme, wenn ich sie nicht mehr brauche. So ressourcensparend, keine Ahnung wieso, habe ja 8G, 4Cores, keine Ahnung. Wird alles immer sauber weggeschlossen. Und wenn irgendwas, wenn ich sehe, dass der Papierkorb irgendwie, wenn da was Weißes ist, also wenn er nicht leer ist, wird er sofort gelöscht. Und manchmal ärgere ich mich, dass ich die ganzen Scheiß immer sofort lösche, weil eigentlich soll es ja eine Weile drin liegen, dass ich denke, so was ist da noch? Oh Gott, das will ich ja vielleicht doch gar nicht löschen, aber ich lösche immer alles. Und dann, wenn ich zu anderen Leuten komme und die wollen wieder, hier Dennis, mach mir doch mal irgendwas Folgendes heilen, und ich sehe, dass der Papierkorb voll ist, dann hab ich schon immer so den Instinkt, das kloppe ich jetzt weg, und dann denke ich, naja, nee, vielleicht wollen die ja, dass da die Sachen noch so drin sind, und ich lösche den immer nicht, aber immer voll so die Überwindung, so, ah, nee, nicht löschen. Aber das ist eigentlich voll fies, eigentlich sollte der gar nicht anzeigen, dass er irgendwie Inhalt hat, oder?
Und das ist noch viel fieser. Ein iPhoto gibt es ja auch in Papierkorb, und da ändert sich das Icon nicht, egal ob der leer ist oder voll.
Bei wo?
In iPhoto. Der Papierkorb sieht immer so aus, als wäre was drin, und dann will ich den löschen, und dann ist er schon leer, aber er sieht noch voll aus.
Das ist ja besonders fies.
Der sieht immer so aus, als ob er leer ist, als er voll ist. Echt?
Ja, und es war iPhoto oder es ist Aperture, keine Ahnung.
Warte mal, ich lösche mal meinen, ich mach mal empty Trash, nee das stimmt nicht, der sieht anders aus.
Dann war es Aperture.
So viel Zeit muss sein. Ja, also ich mache auch ganz regelmäßig und oft schon total unterbewusst, das ist so ein Automatismus, diesen Shortcut zum Papier und dieses schöne Krrrrrrrr, dieses schöne Krrrrrr Geräusch, das er so kurz er tönt, ja das macht...
Wo wir gerade von 751 geredet haben, kenn ich eigentlich auch diese Extention damals, die dafür gesorgt hat, dass wenn man den Müll einmal gelöscht hat, da dieser Oscar aus der Mülltonne kam und die Tonne mehr gemacht hat, vermisse ich ja so ein bisschen. Das könnte jetzt so smooth sein, dann wären wir wieder bei 60 FPS und dann wieder so den...
Ein Open GL-Oscar.
War schon ganz witzig damals.
Okay, Aperture lehrt den Papierkorb nicht, aus irgendeinem Grund.
So, dann möchtest du eine Lücke haben, dann kann ich ja voll frech mich reinwerfen in diese Lücke und kann ein bisschen über Safari 5.2 abbranten. Und zwar rantet man ja mal besonders gerne, wenn eigentlich einem die Features gefallen, aber sie irgendwie dann doch nicht so richtig nutzbar sind, weil ich hätt sie ja schon gerne. Hab also Safari 5.2 entzählt, alles voll toll. Darf man überhaupt erzählen als Developer? Darf man gar nicht erzählen, ist mir egal, ist ja zu spät. So, was kommt woher?
Das 5.2.
Na, wahrscheinlich von Apple, von Developer Union. Ist egal, das raus hat mir ein Kumpel erzählt. Da ist halt die Suchbar von Google oder Yahoo oder was wollen wir nennen? Bing, Bing, ja doch Bing. Und die Adressleiste ist irgendwie so zusammenge-polymorphed, nee gemorphed.
Ist jetzt wie bei Chrome, Unified, Address and Search.
Das ist eigentlich ganz cool, weil da habe ich mich ja voll schnell dran gewöhnt. Aber was halt irgendwie nicht geht, ist, dass ich irgendwie meine Suchhistory nicht mehr habe, sondern man muss halt jetzt in dem einen Input-Field, in der Texteingabe, da musst du halt irgendwie los tippen, damit du dann erst irgendwie die History von sowohl den UALs, wo du schon mal gewesen bist, als auch vor den Suchen, die du schon mal getätigt hast, irgendwie bekommst. Und dann musst du da irgendwie hinfallen. Also das ist nicht mehr so schön getrennt wie vorher. Dafür sieht natürlich diese Auflöstung, die ist jetzt zweizeitig pro Eintrag, nämlich das, was du getippt hast und das, was wirklich als UAL dir dann rauskommen würde. Also sieht alles viel schicker aus und so. Aber es ist, ja, da müssen die noch irgendwie was machen. Ich weiß nicht, was die sich mal machen müssen.
Das ist Beta-Software. Ich meine, das ist nun echt nicht fertig.
Ja, aber das Konzept ist doch schon klar, in welche Richtung die wollen. Da kann man ja mal drüber reden. Du willst jetzt hier den Max machen?
Nein, aber Apple hat bei Safari auch schon mal ganz andere Dinger gebracht. Die haben schon auf ihrer Webseite groß angekündigt, dass sie den jetzt rausbringen und der hat diese tollen, komischen Invertierten-Taps. Das stand schon auf apple.com und das kam nicht im Release.
Du meinst diese Chrome-Taps oben in der...
Ja, haben sie dann noch rausgeschmissen. Das ist so nie released worden. Das war nur in der Beta-Version drin.
Ja, ich will ja schon mal sagen, was ich gut finde und was ich nicht gut finde. Also, das Combined Search Bar und Oil Bar finde ich voll cool. Also, dass ich aber meine Suchhistorie nicht mehr habe, finde ich nicht cool, dass sie mehr Info pro History dann halt anzeigen. Wenn es da so runterklappt, das ist voll cool, weil dann kannst du besser genau sehen, wo du landen würdest. Das ist alles voll schick. Flutschen tut er auch. Die Tabs sind jetzt irgendwie nicht immer gleich groß, sondern die nutzen die volle Breite. Wenn zwei sind, dann teilen die sich auch wirklich die Breite. Das ist auch cool, weil das passt halt viel mehr hin. Und du willst ja schon den Titel irgendwie lesen. Und ja, was war da eigentlich noch so neu? Ja, also schnell wie Sauware sowieso. Wobei der 514, der jetzt irgendwie gestern oder vorgestern rauskam, der ist auch noch mal. Das flutscht wieder sowas von. Also, da sind die echt noch am Machen und Tun.
Das war aber auch bitter nötig. Seit Safari kam die Umstellung mit 5.1 auf die mehrere Prozesse, oder war das mit Safari? Ne, 5.1, ne? Da haben sie auf WebKit 2 umgestellt. Das heißt mehrere Prozesse im Hintergrund, aber eben nicht wie bei Chrome. Chrome macht einen neuen Prozess auf und macht da seinen Tab drin.
Sondern das WebKit selbst macht das jetzt so.
Das WebKit selber macht das halt irgendwie. Das ist ein bisschen unklar, wer da jetzt eigentlich so wirklich den Hut auf hat. Und seit Safari 5.1 ist bei mir die ganze Safari-Experience massiv in den Keller gegangen. So sehr, dass ich auf dem alten Rechner schon auf Chrome umgestiegen bin. Weil es einfach nicht benutzbar war.
Ich benutze ja seit eh und jedes Nightly-Bild-Webkit. Und das war flutschig eigentlich immer.
Hast du einen Quadco eigentlich?
Ich mag auch Release so. Das finde ich irgendwie auch gut, weil Nightly klar kann irgendein Problem lösen, kann aber auch das nächste Problem schon wieder mit auf den Tisch bringen.
So selten passiert das.
Was habe ich, ob ich einen Quadcore habe? Ich habe hier einen 8-Core.
Und da hat es auch nicht getan?
Auf dem Mac Pro war es nie so schlimm wie auf den anderen. Ob das jetzt was mit den Cores zu tun hat.
Na ja, nur wenn die da voll Shredding machen, dann muss man natürlich auch was haben, weil das irgendwie abarbeitet.
Sie haben auf jeden Fall eine Menge zu tun. Ich habe so den Eindruck, die Updates der letzten Zeit haben die Gesamtsituation etwas verbessert.
Aber es ist halt immer noch eine Menge zu tun. Ich habe jetzt wieder, wie gesagt, das 52 hat so Sachen, da bin ich nicht mit klarkommen. Vor allem irgendwann crasht das auch wie blöd. Habe ich wieder zurückgestuft und das 514 jetzt ist schon ordentlich flutschig. Aber ich hätte schon gerne diese kombinierte Such- und UL-Bar.
Aber wie gesagt, das Nightly-Wipkit ist gecrashed mit dem Safari 52. Der Safari 52 so an sich, der läuft stable.
Wollen wir noch ein bisschen in die Zukunft gucken?
Ja, warte, eine Sache noch. Noch so ein Thema, wo Max ja total begeistert war, bei dieses iMessage oder Messages oder wie heißt es?
Meinst du die App oder das Foto-Call?
Die App auf Desktop und Phone, Messages. Irgendwie Dennis, mein Telefon fängt so an zu vibrieren, rhythmisch, okay, was ist das so, guck so nach, okay, Dennis schreibt, alles klar. Na ist ja schön, wenn Dennis schreibt und Dennis schreibt schnell, Dennis schreibt sehr schnell und es vibriert so zack, zack, Zeile nach Zeile, Moment, der tippt nicht auf dem Telefon, der schreibt jetzt gerade mit der Messages-App. So, okay, ich so Kopfkratz, okay, hm, also es kommt auf dem Phone an, alles klar, jetzt starte ich mal die Messages-App, weil irgendwie auf dem Desktop gab es jetzt keine Notifikation, starte ich mal, vielleicht kommt es ja dann so, nö, kommt erstmal nicht, okay, hm, warum nicht? Also Dennis schreibt mir, aber es kommt nicht.
Redest du jetzt von welcher Plattform redest du jetzt?
Genau, so, starte ich also diese Messages-App auf Lion, kommt aber da, kommen aber Dennis Nachrichten nicht an, sondern tauschen wir uns also über iPhone-Messages aus, an wen er denn jetzt die iMessage geschickt hat. Und du hast es an die Nummer geschickt gehabt, ne? So, okay, und dann stellte es sich raus, obwohl ich eigentlich der Meinung war, ich hätte mich mit Messages mit meiner Apple-ID eingesigned, dass ich tatsächlich Messages mit meiner Telefonnummer benutze. Wo jetzt? Auf dem Telefon. Moment. Moment, ja, das Ding ist halt, jetzt dachte ich, okay, aber ich hatte ja schon mal dieses Phänomen, dass ich auf Phone und in der Messages-App auf dem Desktop die Nachrichten kriege, war aber nebenbei. Okay, ich habe in beiden den Nachrichten, in den Settings geguckt. Auf dem Desktop war ich mit meiner Apple-ID mit Messages verbunden, auf dem iPhone nur mit meiner Nummer. Gut, dann habe ich also jetzt gedacht, alles klar, nee, nicht eigentlich alles klar. Ich trage jetzt mal auf dem iPhone in den Settings meine Apple-ID mit dazu, dass geht. Du kannst ja mehrere ID's in deinen Messages-App hinzufügen. So, und dann irgendwie füge ich in meinem Kontakt irgendwie auf dem Desktop auch noch meine Telefonnummer dazu, damit irgendwie er weiß, es ist alles das Gleiche. So, dann habe ich Dennis gesagt, hier schicken wir noch mehr. Kann man aber nix. Also kam nur auf dem Phone, immer noch nicht auf dem Desktop. Gut, dachte ich, okay, jetzt schreibe ich Dennis auf dem Desktop auch noch mal eine Nachricht an seine, an sein Phone sozusagen, ja, klick also dieses Menü, ist nur das blaue Bubbletchen gegen seine, bei seiner E-Mail-Adresse halt, ne. Aber er schickt die ganze Zeit Messages halt von der Telefonnummer, mit der er auf dem iPhone oder so, ne. Okay, schicke ich ihm eine Message, eine iMessage an seine Telef... Also vom Desktop, von der Messages-App schicke ich ein Dennis-Telefonnummer, eine iMessage und hoffe jetzt natürlich, dass es bei ihm auf beiden Geräten auch ankommt und wenn er mir eine Antwort zurückkommt, dass es auch auf beiden ankommt. Aber es ging einfach nicht. Also es kam nichts mehr auf meinem Desktop an, nur noch auf dem Phone.
Wann da was wo kommt, ist irgendwie nicht so klar. Und vor allem immer gleichzeitig. Also du bist voll am Desktop, am tippen wie ein Weltmeister. Ich meine, wir chatten. Weiß nicht, waren es andere Leute, so chatten so. Ich bin gleich da und das war's schon. Aber ich will ja da auch diskutieren, labern machen, tun und das ganze Zeit das Telefon vibriert und das ist massig, das Telefon leer.
Also dieser, wo Max meinte, alles super und es total übersichtlich. Das war so irgendwie, ich saß da zehn Minuten davor. Was willst du von mir? Wie komme ich an diese Messages ran? Und wie, es war überhaupt nicht nachvollziehbar, wie man das jetzt hinkriegen kann. Vom Desktop die Nachricht, die ich Dennis schicke, die er beantwortet, er sieht sie, beantwortet sie auf dem Phone und sie kommt aber nicht da an, also die Antwort kommt nicht da an, wo ich die Anfrage abgeschickt habe, sondern auf einem anderen Gerät.
Das Problem ist übrigens auch gar nicht neu, das gab's schon vorher, das war euch wahrscheinlich so nie aufgefallen, mit Facetime. Naja, aber es ist genau dasselbe.
Ich hatte auch ein Problem mit Messages und zwar wir hatten ja hier live Messages ausprobiert und Max hatte mir ja per Messages relativ viele Messages geschickt. Und dann bin ich am nächsten Tag in der Firma, mach da den Rechner an, da fährt natürlich auch Messages hoch.
Und dann kommen die alle.
Dann kommen die alle und ich denk mir, prima, guck mir das an, alles klar, mach was anderes, sehe ich am Messages ist wieder dieses diese Notification-Bubble, neue Messages. Gehe ich wieder rüber? Nee, es sind immer noch die gleichen wie vorher. Guck die mir, wechsel nochmal rum, wechsel wieder hin zu Max Kram, ist Bubble wieder weg. Wechsel ich wieder die Applikation, dauert es wieder zwei Minuten, ist wieder der Unread-Bubble da. Das ging irgendwie den halben Tag so, dann habe ich Max noch mal geschrieben, dass da irgendwie ständig der Böppel abgeht. Und Max dann so zurück, das ist ja schlecht. Und dann irgendwie hörte das aber nicht auf und am nächsten Tag war das Phänomen dann weg.
Super.
Ich sag dir, dieses iMessage, das sind die Vorboten der Zombo-Kalypse. Zombie-Kalypse. Also es ist einfach, das ist doch die untoten Nachrichten stellen dir nach. Du kannst sie die ganze Zeit irgendwie wegschießen. Ja, ich habe dich gelesen. Kommen sie immer wieder und du wirst in die los.
Das ist irgendwie nicht wie ich 21. Jahrhundert mir vorgestellt hab.
Vor allem auch so dieses, weißt du SMS war immer so, hat sowas Vertrautes gehabt. Du weißt, das geht dann zum Telefon und nur zu einem Telefon. Ich hab mir immer Angst haben, dass mir jemand eine Nachricht schickt, die dann auf irgendwelchen Computern, die auch gerade an sind und wo ich eingeloggt bin, auch kommen. Also so zu Hause oder so. Was nicht so der Ort ist, wo ich so SMS haben will.
Mit SMS hatte ich das Phänomen aber auch schon mal. Da bin ich irgendwann nach England gefahren. Und zwar bei meiner damalige Freundin Belgierin war sind wir also mit dem Zug durch Luxemburg nach Belgien gefahren und von Belgien dann über Frankreich nach England. So und irgendjemand hatte eine SMS zum falschen Zeitpunkt gesendet. Und jedes dieser Netze, jedes dieser Ländernetze, durch das ich durchgefahren bin, war der Meinung mir eine frische neue SMS zu stellen.
Und du hast auch schön jedes Mal bezahlt?
Ne, ich glaube nicht. Aber es war irgendwie so, dein Telefon bucht sich hinter der Grenze neu ein und dann meint er, prima, ich habe gleich mal eine SMS für dich.
Aber ne, also ich weiß nicht, also ich meine vor allen Dingen, die werden noch aus. Und da, das ist wieder so ein Problem auch oder so eine Situation, da denkt man sich doch, die benutzen das doch auch, die probieren das doch aus. Wieso haben die nicht diese Probleme, ja? Also ich meine, wir testen das so aus dem Spaß aus, nicht mal professionell und es geht total katastrophal schief mit dieser Zustellung von diesen Messages. Wie muss das denn bei denen sein? Haben die keine Tests? Wie kann so ein Stück kaputter Kram irgendwie das Licht der Welt erblicken? Das ist mir echt ein Rätsel. Also selbst wenn es Beta ist, irgendwie, das kriegt ja, ne, das sag ich jetzt nicht. Aber ist ja, also irgendwie so, versteh ich nicht.
Mit der Apple ID hab ich auch merkwürdige Probleme. Es ist ja so, irgendwann gab's ja mal.mec und dann gab's mobile.me. Jetzt gibt's iCloud. Das heißt, wenn man.mec hatte, hatte mac.com Adresse und die wurde irgendwann zu einer mobile.me, sprich me.com Adresse. So, jetzt hab ich eine Apple ID, wo sowohl eine.me, also eine.me.com, als auch eine mac.com Adresse dran ist. Auf dem iPhone, wenn ich da eine Mail verschicke, nimmt er die.me.com Adresse. Wenn ich auf dem Mac eine Mail verschicke, nimmt er auch die.me.com Adresse, aber wenn ich auf dem iPad eine Mail verschicke, nimmt er die mac.com Adresse und ich weiß nicht, wie man das ändert.
Und das wahrscheinlich mit gesynchten Settings.
Ja, natürlich.
Das ist Mail Syncing, das ist auch wirklich kaputt, da kämpfe ich auch schon seit Tagen.
Mail Syncing, aber macht das nicht IMAP für einen?
IMAP synkt die Mail-Inhalt, aber die Mail-Settings, die Filter-Rolls in diesen ganzen Klimpen.
Das ist total absurd.
Ich hab zum Beispiel so den Pfeil, Mailing-Liste kommt rein, über Account willst du in einen bestimmten Ordner rein.
Aber das machst du doch auf dem Server hoffentlich, oder nicht?
Nein, das mach ich nicht auf dem Server. Weil ich gerade, weil ich erstens nicht nur einen Server habe, sondern mehrere und zweitens, das für mich nicht mehr händelbar gewesen ist, das auf dem Server zu machen. Vor allem nicht, wenn man so diese, wie soll ich sagen, wenn man eine gewisse Dynamik in seinen Mailbox Benamungen und Strukturen beibehalten möchte. Dann hast du mit so einer Server-Konfiguration immer alles sehr festgefahren und ich würde mir auch mal sehr wünschen, dass sie sowas in iCloud oder wo auch immer einbauen, aber hat ja bisher noch keiner vorgesehen.
Ich hab ja meine ganzen Mail-Counts alle auf einen Mail-Counts zeigen lassen und dann sozusagen in meiner Inbox habe ich unter Folder für jede E-Mail-Adresse und dann, das hab ich gemacht, damit ich dann auf dem Server zentral alles filtern kann, damit auf allen Devices die Mail einfach immer im richtigen Ordner liegt.
Da will ich auch mal wieder hin. Das ist cool. Ja, da war ich mal und jetzt will ich aber da weg und jetzt will ich da hin und bis ich dann irgendwie mal alles so umgestellt habe. Aber das ist halt genau das Problem. Dann hab ich so Filterhosen, stell die irgendwie so ein, hab ich so zwei Rechner und dann hab ich irgendwie einmal einen Fehler gemacht, dass ich es auf dem einen Rechner im falschen Account in den Folder des selben Namens gepackt habe, also Mailing-Listen-Name auf Account A und auf dem anderen Mailing-Listen-Name ein Folder auf Account B. Und dann ändere ich das irgendwie von B nach A auf dem, wo es falsch stand und denke mir so save und sync und tralala und dann vergeht irgendwie ein Tag und völlig unvorhersagbar sind dann einzelne Rechner meines Gesamt-Setups von allem, was so miteinander gesynkt ist, ist dann der Meinung, das ist dann doch wieder in B rein zu tun und ich weiß, ich habe es jetzt schon sechs oder sieben Mal geändert und das ist wirklich traurig.
Also ich glaube, das mit dem Synking wird auch nichts mehr. Wir sehen uns, das war herbei, aber je mehr Synking wir kriegen, desto schlimmer wird alles.
Ja, aber das ist The Next Steve Jobs. Ja, also wer Wikipedia ablöst und wer das mit dem Synking hinkriegt, können wir mir echt durchaus vorstellen.
The Next Synk Jobs. Ich verliere so langsam den Glauben daran, weil es ist jetzt schon fucking 2012, versteht er? Die Schonfrist ist jetzt so langsam abgelaufen.
Checkt das mal, 2012.
Das mit dem Synking, das wird jetzt so langsam so ein Treppenwitz wie Spracherkennung oder Drucken.
Html hat auch eine Weile gebraucht, bis es funktioniert hat.
Ja, es ist alles elend, es gibt ja noch mehr schlechte Nachrichten, wir haben ja bei einem anderes US-Update noch überhaupt nicht geredet, es gab ja noch iOS 5.1. Habt ihr wahrscheinlich mitbekommen.
Ja, man kann jetzt auf dem Log-Screen so schön die Kamera hoch und runter schieben.
Und zurück. Und zurück.
Und ansonsten war nix.
Doch. Doch, meine. Sie haben die Kapitelmarken verkackt in der Podcast, in der Musik und in der Video ab. Also es gibt jetzt zwar noch welche, aber sie heißen alle Kapitel 1, oder? Nee, der nummeriert sich schon durch, Kapitel 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, was ja schön ist, wenn er irgendwie so hinschreibt, 15 Punkt und dann Kapitel 15. Oh, really? Das 15. Kapitel heißt Kapitel 15? Wie kommt sowas durch die Qualitätssicherung? Na? Na? Na? Niemand in der Qualitätssicherung hört Podcasts. Oder testet überhaupt irgendwas.
Aber ich hab's glaub ich schon öfter erzählt, dass ich den Bug habe, aber bisher ist er immer wieder gekommen, bisher ist er noch nicht wieder gekommen bei 5.1 und zwar werden jetzt die Bilder, die man gemacht hat, wirklich in der Reihenfolge angezeigt, wie man sie gemacht hat und nicht irgendwann neu durchgeschaffelt. Ich glaube das liegt daran, weil ich irgendwie immer das Backup-mäßig eingespielt hab oder irgendwie so. Jedenfalls waren bei mir die Bilder nicht mehr in der Original-Reihenfolge. Nur so grob, aber ineinander irgendwie voll durcheinander. Und bisher, seit 5.1, stimmt's noch. Also es könnte sein, dass sie es mal gelöst haben.
Ich kann auf jeden Fall jedem, der seriös Podcasts empfiehlt, nur raten, von der iTunes-Podcast-Infrastruktur wegzukommen. Also wenn man mit dem iPhone hört, sollte man das nicht mehr mit dem eingebauten Bordmitteln tun. Mittlerweile gehe ich da in eine ganz andere Richtung als das noch vor einem Jahr war. Ich hatte immer so ein bisschen Angst vor diesen Ups, aber mittlerweile, finde ich, hat sich der Wind komplett gedreht. Und ja, ich weiß nicht, ihr Podcasts, iPhone, wie macht ihr das? Du hast keine und du?
Ich habe Podcasts, ja. Ich schmeiß die halt einfach auf so ein iPod und dann drücke ich auf Play.
Du hast mit deinem iPhone keine Podcasts? Du würst die auf den iPod?
Aufs iPhone und...
Du würst die da drauf?
Ja, mit iTunes schmeiße ich die.
Du singst mit iTunes deine Podcasts?
Manuell halt, ich hab nicht einen automatischen Musiksync oder so, ich dreck das Pfeil aufs iPhone und dann ist es da und dann geh ich auf Music, also auf den Music Player iPhone und suche nach Podcast XY und drücke auf Play.
Okay, du hörst nicht viel Podcasts.
Also ich hör auch immer damit. Das ist zwar nicht toll, aber es geht.
Hörst du eigentlich viel Podcasts?
Pfeil?
Drecks? Nein, nein, ich hab das natürlich in iTunes abonniert und dann synkt er das halt rüber.
Okay, wir benutzen immer den Standard-Wick.
Hörst du viele Podcasts?
Ich hör so viele Podcasts, wie ich kann.
Was denn?
Das ist nicht sehr viel derzeit, aber was?
Was denn? Unsere Konkurrenz?
Es gibt keine Konkurrenz, es gibt Mitbewerber.
Unsere Partner-Podcasts.
Auch?
Ich höre alles, was ich gerade so für interessant halte, aber es gibt wenige Podcasts, die ich regelmäßig höre, aber ich höre mittlerweile sehr intensiv, wie so viele andere ja auch, bei 5x5, 5x5 Networks, vor allem Talkshow, Hypercritical und so, wo ich dazu komme, auch Critical Path. Das sind für mich eigentlich die interessantesten Angebote. Also John Groba, John Siracusa, der von Ars Technica, der immer die OS-Reviews macht, der sich übrigens die letzten beiden seiner Podcasts ausführlichst über die Fallsystems Situationen unter OS X markiert hat und die Geschichte von ZFS. Also all das noch mal runtergebetet hat in den zwei Sendungen, was wir jetzt hier eigentlich seit drei Jahren immer wieder auf Repeat von uns gegeben haben. Vielleicht hört ihr ja hier auch ein bisschen rein, kann ja durchaus sein. Und dann höre ich immer wieder so Sachen, die neu sind. Also wann auch immer ein Podcast bei mir so auf den Radar kommt, dass der irgendwie neu ist, dann höre ich da mal rein und dann ist immer die Frage, wie lange mich das so in Bann schlägt.
Dieses Hypercritical mit dem Syracusa und dem Gruber, treffen die sich richtig oder ist das so ein Skype-Ding?
Der Gruber macht Talkshow und der Syracusa macht Hypercritical, obwohl es auch schon mal Shows gab, wo beide zusammen waren. Aber das ist eher die Ausnahme. Also das mit dem Syracusa ist sehr interessant. Der redet sehr schnell, also man muss schon gut Englisch können.
Kann man ja langsamer machen.
Kann man langsamer machen. Der Gruber, finde ich, redet extrem verständlich und langsam. Und ich finde immer sehr interessant, wie er so seine Antworten so herleitet.
Ja, dem habe ich schon mal ein Video gesehen, wo er irgendwie so einen Vortrag gehalten hat. Ich finde so live kamen, dann bin ich so cool.
Der Siracusa hat auch so einen schönen Blogpost, den habe ich letztens mal wieder gefunden, paste ich hier mal gleich in den Chat. Zum Thema Pasta kochen. Er hat ja italienische Wurzeln, wie der Name auch vermuten lässt. Und jeder, der so ein bisschen ernsthaft mal eine Pasta kochen will, also nicht so Miracoli oder Soße aus dem Glas oder so, dem sei doch dieser Post ans Herz gelegt, der enthält wirklich sinnvolle Tipps zum Thema Pasta kochen.
Ja, nochmal kurz zu den Podcasts. Also ich höre mittlerweile alles mit Instacast. Ich bin ganz zufrieden mit Instacast. Nicht, dass mir da nicht noch Features fehlen würden, aber ich finde es ganz toll. Ich finde es natürlich vor allem deshalb toll, weil da Flatter eingebaut ist. Das ist ja die erste App überhaupt, die Flatter eingebaut hat. Denn es gibt jetzt die Möglichkeit, für Entwickler die Flatter-AP zu nehmen und quasi als Klickvermittler zu agieren. Du hast also eine Software, die flatterbaren Content anzeigt oder zugänglich macht und dabei eben auch diesen Flatter-Button dafür zugänglich macht und Leute klicken durch deine App dadurch. Dann kannst du zur Flatter gehen und sagen, hier gib mir mal einen Developer Key, dass ich hier irgendwie registriert bin über die AP und identifizierbar bin mit meiner App. Und man kann dann eben die auch ansprechen auf so ein Deal, dass man eben auch noch beteiligt wird. Das heißt, dieser 10%-Cut, den Flatter eigentlich nimmt pro Klick, der wird dann nochmal aufgeteilt und man kann quasi am Flattern mitverdienen.
Das heißt, die schnappen sich nicht was von den 90%, die beim Künstler ankommen, sondern die schnappen sich was von 10%, das heißt, Flatter gibt ein bisschen was ab, wenn die Leute das...
Also für die Geflatterten ist es völlig egal, womit man geflattert wurde. Aber es ist jetzt für jemanden, der Application-Developer ist, eben nicht egal, sondern man kann eben in dem Moment, wo man das durchreicht, kriegt man quasi eine Durchreich-Provision.
Tribut!
Ja, was ich eigentlich ganz cool finde. Und Five by Five, dieses Netzwerk hat jetzt auch angefangen, Flatter zu verwenden. Das ist eigentlich die erste wirklich populäre Podcast-Plattform international, die das jetzt zum Einsatz bringt. Die sind glaube ich noch nicht so richtig davon überzeugt, wer Five by Five hört und der Meinung ist, sie sollten auch mal pro Sendung, wie das ja bei uns eigentlich gang und gäbe ist, da einen eigenen Button anbieten auf der Webseite, dann kann ich euch nur raten, doch da mal hinzuschreiben und denen das zu erzählen, weil ich glaube, die sind gerade auch ein bisschen überrascht von dem Zuspruch.
Das Flatter hat ja Europa immer noch nicht so richtig verlassen, ne?
Nee, das würde ich auf jeden Fall mal unterstützen, finde ich auf jeden Fall cool mit diesem Flatter-Button, dass die mal ein bisschen über einen großen Teich kommen. Ich unterstütze die. Ich flatter ja gelegentlich einfach Twitter-Accounts um die. Aber das sieht dann halt kein anderer natürlich, ne? Also es ist jetzt immer noch was anderes, als wenn jemand so sagt, so ich hier Leute, es gibt jetzt Flatter, ist cool, mach das mal. Als wenn ich dann so heimlich stillen alleine für mich und Twitter-Account flatter, ne? Das erzeugt nicht viel Schwung, machst du sozusagen, im Gegensatz zu das mal öffentlich irgendwo auf eine Seite kleben, so wie jetzt war bei 5x5, sollten mal mehr machen.
Du kannst ja zumindest sagen, dass deine Klicks public sein sollen bei Flatter, dein Profile einstellen, weiß nicht, ob du das schon mal erwogen hast.
Ich glaube, das habe ich irgendwann mal umgestellt sogar.
Ja, dann ist das schon recht öffentlich.
Ja, aber um jetzt sozusagen noch Leute, die nicht bei Flatter sind, zu kriegen, meine ich, oder darauf hinzuweisen, also, ich meine, jetzt zeigen sie ja auch überall noch das Dollar-Zeichen mit an, damit irgendwie sich die Amis noch ein bisschen wohler fühlen und so.
Wer zeigt das Dollar-Zeichen an?
Flatter, dachte ich. Steht da jetzt nicht überall Dollar und Euro in der Abrechnung?
Ach so, im Dashboard. Ja, du kannst jetzt noch eine andere Währung angeben, in die dann diese Euro-Beträge auch noch mit angezeigt werden. Schönes Feature, ich weiß nicht, ob wir das schon mal erwähnt haben, aber ich sag's einfach mal nochmal hier bei Instacast, du kannst das Instacast ja auch so konfigurieren, dass alles, was du hörst und was flatterbar ist, automatisch geflattert wird, wenn du es hörst.
Okay, bei 5x5, wenn die jetzt sagen, das ganze Netzwerk ist nur flatterbar, ist dann in deinem Instacast pro Folge dann trotzdem dieser Flatter Support?
Die haben pro Episode einen Button, bloß nicht auf der Webseite, aber sie haben ihn im Feed. Das ist noch ein bisschen halb gar. Ich glaube, das ist noch nicht so ganz angekommen. Mich hat das eh schon überrascht, dass das überhaupt stattgefunden hat, weil die natürlich vor allem von Werbung leben. Und das auch nicht so schlecht, sobald ich das einschätzen kann. Ich meine, wenn man sich so ihre Werbetarife anschaut, etc. Also das spielt in einer anderen Liga. Aber die haben ja auch höherer Zahlen, die in einer anderen Liga spielen. Das ist ja da sozusagen nochmal eine Stelle mehr als bei uns. Und von daher, was jetzt auch nicht so überrascht, weil es ja nochmal Englisch, mit so vielen weltweit bekannten Protagonisten, ist es natürlich auch nicht sehr schwierig. Aber es ist schon erstaunlich, wie populär Podcasts auf dem Level überhaupt sind. Dass es da so ein Medium gibt, wo so jede Woche, was weiß ich, 250.000 Leute sich irgendwie so eine Show geben. Schon krass. Hamas.
Hamas?
Da ist schon alles voll.
Israel.
Die ist alles voll. Naja, das ist das, worüber wir so geredet haben. Der Rest ist eigentlich nur noch so klimbim.
Oh, das ist ein paar klimbim.
Aber los, lass mal den Roddy noch ein bisschen über Literals erzählen. Bisschen Spaß muss sein.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das so interessant ist, weil das ist nur ein Klängkommit gewesen, das jemand auseinandergenommen hat. Insofern...
Sind wir jetzt bei Mobile Max Xtreme?
Nee, das machen wir nächste Folge bei Mobile Max Xtreme.
Ich bin ja übrigens immer noch so schwer begeistert von meinen zwei kleinen Menu Bar Tools. Ich bin ja immer sehr skeptisch, neue Menu Bar Tools hinzuzufügen. Aber das eine ist ja dieses Divi immer noch, um irgendwie so Fenster mit Tastaturkürzel und so auf so einem Grid aufzuteilen. Kennste das? Divi? Ring Sebell. Genau, das ist irgendwie immer wieder doch ganz schön. Und das ist jetzt sowieso nach Langzeit-Benutzung. Ich zeige, du guckst du skeptisch rau, die kennst du das nicht, da kannst du so irgendwie deine Windows halt so schön gridmäßig aufteilen. Das ist sehr praktisch auch für Live-Koden und so mal was zeigen oder deine Terminals. Divi, da gibt es noch ein anderes Tool, dessen Namen ich immer vergesse, ich benutze Divi ist super.
Schade für das andere Tool.
Schade für das andere Tool. Und dann hab ich ja, weil iCal so scheiße ist, benutze ich ja Fantastical jetzt so. Das ist ja auch nur so ein Menübar-Kalender. Aber der ist echt cool, so für Menübar-Kalender ist der genau das, was ich so brauche. Weil der macht halt auch so Sachen wie zum Beispiel tippst du dann so einen Zahnarzt, ach so ich hab mein Keyboard umgestellt, Zahnarzt ja zum Beispiel und da, ach scheiße, Keyboard umgestellt. Und dann tippst du halt irgendein Datum rein und er macht dann hier, also er passt das dir automatisch gleich zusammen. Du musst eigentlich überhaupt nichts mehr klicken. Du kannst einfach so Divi aufmachen, los tippen, Zahnarzt 23. Sonst, dann um 17 Uhr und der klickt dir den Event automatisch gleich rein. Voll geil, das ist so genau so mein Kalender-Workflow. Ich will diese Kalender ab gar nicht aufmachen, wenn ich nicht unbedingt wirklich muss. So, das wollte ich nochmal gesagt haben. Hab ich geschickt gemacht, ne Tim?
Aber da gibt es ja immer noch keine Entlastung.
Ja, da kann ich auch noch ein kurzes Ding zu sagen. Also ich hab's nicht wirklich benutzt bis jetzt, es ist mir nur aufgefallen, iCalBuddy, ich weiß nicht, ob ihr das schon mal gehört habt, ist ein Kommandozeilen-Tool im Terminal, was man über Homebrew installieren kann und dann kann man per Kommandozeile irgendwie seine Kalenderevents machen.
Ach. Back to the Shell, sag ich nur.
Genau, Back to the Shell.
Back to the Shell.
Und was machst du damit?
Nix, das ist mir nur aufgefallen. Ich wollte es erwähnt haben.
Ja und wenn ihr im Terminal einfach, wie war das, Kall eingeben, das ist sowieso der beste Kalender von allen. Da kann man sogar, wie, was macht denn das?
So, der Chat fragt, ob ich schon was zu Scro-Lend-Are gesagt habe. Was ist denn das?
Dieser Name, sie haben sich wirklich getraut.
Ich hab das hier tatsächlich mal installiert, nachdem das heute irgendjemand getwittert hat. Ja, ganz nett. Ich weiß nicht, es ist ganz merkwürdig. Ich hab ja sozusagen das Fehlen einer Macintosh-Anwendung geklagt, die ordentlich funktioniert, worauf ich nicht permanent auf irgendwelche iOS-Apps verwiesen werde. It's not the point, dass ich nicht der Meinung bin, dass man das hier auch noch verbessern könnte. Aber es geht mir wirklich vor allem und primär um den Mac. Aber nichtsdestotrotz, jetzt gibt es auch noch Scro-Lend-Are, was das mit dem Scrollen so grundsätzlich macht, wie ich das schon immer angeprangert habe, also wochenweise und kontinuierlich. Wobei die Umsetzung da etwas mager ist. Die wollen nicht abzocken. Das farbliche Highlighting ist nicht so gut. Man müsste das noch ein bisschen mehr begleiten. Aber du tippst dann halt irgendwo drauf und dann gibt's nur ein View nur für die ganze Woche, wo dann immer alles hintereinander ist und so weiter. Also das ist natürlich auch Quatsch. Du willst natürlich schon auch mal einen einzelnen Tag sehen. Von daher taugt sowas hier herzlich wenig, um irgendwas abzulösen. Also durchdacht ist anders, aber interessant zu sehen, dass dieses Modell der unendlichen Zeit langsam Fuß fasst.
Hast du es jetzt in den Bitcoin-Channel gepastet?
Ist egal, da passt es ja auch rein. So, hier. Ist ein iPhone-App, womit man, also die User von meinem Pool, womit die, ihre Workers sehen können, wie live, also, wie die arbeiten und die Notifications, ihre Payouts lock, der Pool wieder funktioniert. Und also, die kann in einem alles Statistik sehen, die es halt so gibt. Und man braucht ja dafür so einen sogenannten AP-Key. Und damit das einfach ist, weil man will keine 20 Zeichen, Krypto, Buchstaben eintippen, funktioniert das halt mit QR-Code, den man irgendwie mit Kamera hält, man drauf auf die Webseite und dann wird automatisch der AP-Key übertragen. Und so ist es eigentlich ganz schick. Das Einzige, was nicht geht, ist der Payout-Button. Das ist BTCMP-View, ganz simpel Name. Hab ich da gerade gepostet, da ist der iTunes-Link. Das ist nur für Leute, die mein Pool benutzen. Alle anderen können höchstens Pool-Statistiken gucken, glaube ich. Aber ich weiß gar nicht, ich glaube, ohne...
Ach, der Karsten hat dir das mal gehackt.
Ja, das haben wir über seinen... Der hat gar nichts gehackt, also...
Ich hab das mit meinem anderen Kumpel gemacht.
Nee, wir nutzen immer Karstens Account, damit werden sie die Bude raiden.
Na, Kinder, hört mal zu.
Ihr könnt ja noch was lernen, wie man das macht.
Dann mal das Passwort nicht rumliegen lassen.
Ja, von dem hab ich wirklich alles. Ja, und das jedenfalls ist gerade raus. Payout-Button geht gerade nicht, kommt im nächsten Update 061, aber...
Aber wer hat denn die abgemacht?
Na, ich mit meinem Kumpel.
Echt?
Aber was cool ist, man kann halt, das muss ich euch mal so zeigen, ich glaube, der Max hat der Letzten gezeigt, dass es auch schon andere Programme gibt, die es so machen. Ich glaube, von Apple gibt es inzwischen auch schon irgendein Tool, was es so macht. Also du hast ja hier dieses Tabbar, ne, wie heißt es unten? Die Toolbar, unten ist die Toolbar, ja genau. Und normalerweise muss der unten in der Toolbar so klicken, um irgendwann das hinzukommen, aber bei uns kann man halt auch so machen, weil es einfach viel cooler ist.
Was ist so machen?
Na mit dem Finger so rübersliden in der Mitte. Man muss nicht mehr unten klicken. Swipen, genau. Wir haben da eine Swipe-Gesture.
Guck mal, was ist denn hier los? Die Hörer haben uns verlassen. 400 Hörer-Drop. Was?
Kalender halt.
Da waren sie alle weg.
Jetzt ernsthaft? Warte mal, wo ist hier? Auf Xenim der Graf? Dein Tool ist doch kaputt. Nee, tatsächlich. Oh, da ist irgendwas ganz kaputt, glaube ich, bei Xenim.
Bei Xenim sind einige Teile ausgefallen, oder?
Ja, oder wir haben sie wirklich verjagt. Das kann auch sein. Xenim können wir auch mal gleich flettern, wieder hier.
Da ist wohl irgendwas kaputt gegangen. Aber das heißt nicht, dass die Hörer weg sind, das heißt meistens nur, dass die Statistiken nicht mehr reported werden.
Na gut.
Das sieht man hier auch. Hier gibt es ja auch so ein dickes Loch und dann hat man auch relativ viel Kontinuität.
Ich hätte auch noch ein Tool, was ich noch vorstellen könnte. Das heißt Prompt. Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr schon mal darüber geredet habt.
Command Line für iOS.
Das gibt es doch schon seit ewig.
Das gibt es schon seit ewig.
Das ist doch von den Jungs, die Dings gemacht haben hier, von den Panic-Jungs, oder?
Genau, von denen ist es. Ich hatte vorher mal iSSH verwendet. Das ging mir irgendwann zu sehr auf den Sack. Und dann habe ich doch mal Prompt angeschafft.
Prompt, Prompt angeschafft?
Hab ich mir Prompt, Prompt angeschafft, genau. Es ist irgendwie ein bisschen langsamer, aber viele Dinge sind einfach irgendwie intelligenter, habe ich auch das Gefühl. Das Font-Rendering, das Font-Rendering ist besser. Und überhaupt, also ich finde es gut.
Jetzt da kommt die Jusa wieder, auf unserem Jusameter. Ich muss sagen, ich bin ja eigentlich auch voll der Shell-Hacker, teilweise, ja. Also, ist ja schon auch so mein Ding. Aber ich habe noch nie so ein SSH auf dem iPhone benutzt. Ganz am Anfang, als es noch den App-Store gar nicht gab, da gab es ja dieses Term... Irgendwas mit Term hieß es. So dieses gehackte Ding noch, bevor überhaupt die APs freigegeben waren.
Ja, da konnte man aber lokal irgendwie hacken, ne?
Ja, und halt auch diese App halt, dieses SSH installieren, damit du auch so das nutzen kannst. Aber danach habe ich das nie wieder benutzt.
Ich habe noch ein richtig geiles Tool für Terminal-Hacker und Developer und was nicht noch alles. Ja, jetzt pass auf, jetzt pass auf.
Die Mobile-Max-Wundertüte.
Jetzt schnallt euch mal an. Jetzt sucht mal nochmal den Ghostfest, ja? Also für Leute, die so auf mehreren Maschinen gleichzeitig ein Kommando ausführen wollen, ne? Jetzt kommt's. Da gibt es verschiedene Möglichkeiten. Es gibt so eine Alternative zu dem Kommand-Tool-Screen. Das nennt sich TMUX. Damit kann man im Prinzip auch sowas machen. Mehrere Sessions gleichzeitig aufmachen und dann den Input broadcasten.
Das TMUX haben die gemacht, weil Screen ist, glaube ich, der GPL und die FreeBestellung mögen ja GPL nicht so wirklich. Und deswegen gibt es TMUX.
Und TMUX ist auch cool, aber egal. Na ja, wenn du halt zum Beispiel…
eine iCloud verwalten musst.
Nee, zum Beispiel, ja, zum Beispiel eine iCloud. Aber sag mal, du hast jetzt ein praktisches Beispiel bei unseren hier Facebook-Spielen. Da haben wir halt zehn Application-Server, wo irgendwie das Backend draufläuft. Und dann willst du bei allen zehn halt einen neuen Key deployen oder bei allen zehn irgendeinen… die Prozesse neu starten oder killen oder ein Passwort ändern oder was auch immer. Der eine Weg wäre, du lockst dich jetzt zehnmal da ein und machst das bei jedem einzeln. Oder du lockst dich bei allen zehn ein und broadcastest die Kommandos zu allen zehn Shells. Und da gibt es ein Tool, das das für einen macht. Das heißt CSSHX. Muss man sich auch runterladen.
Wie der Name schon sagt.
Genau. Und wenn du das dann am Start hast, dann ist die Welt plötzlich ganz schön. Weil dann sagst du, egal wie viele Maschinen du hast, der teilt dann die Terminals quasi auch so möglichst gleichmäßig auf deinem Screen auf. Und dann kannst du mit einem...
Du tippst dann an einem und es kommt an allen.
Also ich würd's ja jetzt... Für sowas hätte ich ja so gerne jetzt einen Videopodcast, wo man das einfach mal geschmeidig vorführen kann. Aber ich kann es vielleicht jetzt hier mal... Scheiße.
Aber das ist schon mit Grafik-Support, es ist nicht nur so ein Shell-Script. Weil Shell-Script-mäßig hab ich das irgendwie 2000 schon bei Pixel-Park gekodet, weil da brauchte ich auch sowas.
Naja, also der macht dir halt drei Terminal-Fenster auf und du hast unten ein rotes Command-Terminal und dann kannst du halt...
In den roten tippen und das kommt oben in allen.
Und das Coole ist halt, du kannst dann auch in jedes einzelne Terminal immer noch klicken, wenn du mal einen Command nur nicht broadcasten willst. Also für alle die, die mal so richtig multi... Also es sieht richtig schön aus, wenn du 20 Terminals gleichzeitig aufmachst und dann in allen Terminals gleichzeitig deine Commands und Tops und keine Ahnung was durchscrollen. Also wenn man so richtig Movie-OS-mäßig loshacken will, ja, und Freunde beeindrucken will bei einer Party oder so, dann csshx mit großem x ist das Tool der Wahl.
Wenn man mal wieder Freunde beeindrucken muss.
Auf einer Party.
Genau, so ein richtiger Nerd-Talk. Ich glaube, das ist dann auch wirklich die Abschlepper-Masche schlechthin. Und dann hab ich irgendwie meine 10 Server. Was soll ich dir sagen? Dasselbe Kommando auf allen Rechner. Warte, Moment. Wollten wir nicht noch...
2000 bei Pixel Park gekodet, und da konnte man, hatte ich so Gruppen, verschiedene Rechner, die man sich aussuchen konnte, in welcher Gruppe jetzt dieses Kommando ausgeführt wird. Hast du halt die Backend-Gruppe, und da hast du halt die Frontend-Gruppe, was weiß ich nicht alles, und dann konntest du so eintippen. Dieses Kommando bitte in die Gruppe. Aber ohne schön grafisch und so.
Nee, aber übrigens der Tipp kam hier von Clemens Schrimper auch. Also es haben natürlich ein paar mir getwittert, als ich da nach so einem Tool fragte, aber er hat es mir als erster getwittert. Aus dieser Sendung, bekannt auch aus der Chaos Radio Express Sendung Internet im Festnetz. Ah ja, sorry, das muss rausschneiden. Ja, so eine Tools sind schön. T-Mux, CSS, HX, da kann man... Und ich habe jetzt für alle, die schon immer auf meine Terminal-Settings und Wimps-Settings und so scharf sind, ich habe jetzt einen Github-Repository. Ich forsche jetzt nämlich gerade wieder an einem neuen Terminal Scheme und Wimps-Setting, sodass das auf allen Servern, wo ich eingeloggt bin, gleich aussieht und alles schön mit augenschonenden Kontrasten und so. Ich paste den Link einfach in den Chat und dann können wir das da...
Kann Terminal schon seine Settings über iCloud sünden?
Na, ich mache einen Skript auf jeden Fall dazu, damit man das easy deployen kann. Es ist noch nicht fertig, ja, so bei 80%, aber es sieht schon ganz gut aus, wie ich finde.
Das wäre mal was. Ich bin nicht so sicher. Warum nicht?
Ich weiß nicht, irgendwie das vergessen sie. Egal, sie bauen alles ein, aber...
Die wollen alles in die Cloud haben.
Alle Settings sollten sich...
Sollten.
Ja.
Werden Keychains eigentlich über die iCloud gesynkt?
Nein, das haben sie ja explizit rausgenommen.
Das ist ein bisschen strange. Aber ich meine, jetzt mit Mountainline ist ja schon so, dieses du lockst dich ein und du hast da deinen Setup.
Das funktioniert nicht.
Ich trau der Sache auch nicht. Vor allem, wie gesagt, das wird doch richtig teuer irgendwann. Die wollen ja Kohle, wenn du über 10 GB kommst.
Und dann müssen wir uns doch einen Linux kaufen und dann sind wir am Arsch.
Also hier, was du voll meintest, dass du hast gesagt, du hörst alle deine Podcasts mit Instacast, ne?
Derzeit.
Das heißt, der lädt dich auch runter oder hört er im Stream?
Sowohl als auch.
Angenommen.
Wenn es nicht runtergeladen ist, auch direkt sagen, Stream.
Angenommen, also macht er das auch in die iCloud rein oder wie macht er das?
Über iCloud, also er macht Settings-Sync über iCloud.
Aber er lädt die Podcasts natürlich nicht in die iCloud. Aber angenommen willst du mal welche aufheben.
Ja.
Was mich dann, also ist ja nur ein Beispiel, diesen Instagram könnte man ja auch aus sich irgendein beliebiges andere Programm aussuchen, aber was ich mich halt frage, ist, wenn so ein Programm seine Daten irgendwie, die halt allgemein eigentlich nutzbar sein sollten, wie zum Beispiel Podcast oder irgendwie Musik oder Film, das in die iCloud legt, kann man dann noch irgendwie auf ein anderes Programm wechseln und dann trotzdem an die gleichen Daten rankommen oder ist das alles dann immer noch pro App festgenagelt? Da hab ich immer so ein bisschen Angst um meine Daten, wenn man dann mal wechseln will.
Deine Daten im Sinne von deine gemerkten Podcasts?
Ja, oder angenommen, ich hab jetzt auch hier, wie heißt das, Sketch Pro, da ist irgendwie so ein Bildmalprogramm, ich pinsel mir mein Bild, was wirklich nur ich gemacht hab und nur es einmal gibt und das Programm legt es für mich in die iCloud ab. Ist ja erstmal nicht verkehrt. Aber angenommen, dann denk ich, okay, Sketch Pro ist grad nicht mehr irgendwie das Coole, da gibt es irgendwie New Kit on the Block, heißt irgendwie Schick am Malen, was weiß ich. Und dann geht es aber nicht, weil das Bild halt auf Sketch Pro irgendwie festgenagelt ist. Da hab ich noch so ein bisschen Angst, dass es halt noch nicht so frei dynamisch ist wie auf dem Desktop, wo man seine Dateien halt aufmachen kann, womit man will und wenn es halt mit dem Hex-Editor ist, weil man will es halt mal so reingucken.
Also du kannst, wenn es dir, ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob es dir um deine Favorites ging oder ob es dir generell um deine Subscriptions ging?
Na egal, einfach ein Pfeil aus einem Programm, was in der iCloud liegt.
Bei Instacast kannst du explizit von Dropbox importieren, nach Dropbox exportieren oder deine ganze Subscription-Liste als OPML exportieren.
Ich meine schon speziell iCloud.
Speziell iCloud gibt es nicht. Bei Instacast ist es nur so, wenn du jetzt irgendwie komplett neues iPhone...
Das ist doch so ein Beispiel.
Du hast doch jetzt kein anderes Beispiel sagen. Aber in dem Fall liegt dann halt einfach das Setup da in iCloud und du sollst das einfach aktivieren und dann schwupsen auf einmal alle deine Subscriptions.
Aber man kann nicht mit einer anderen App auf die Dateien von einer dritten App zugreifen. Also ich sag mal Pixelmater auf dem i.
Na du weißt doch, wie das ist. Jedes Programm ford itself. Das ist aber auch erstmal ganz gut so.
Na stell dir vor, du fängst halt an, hast ein Bild, überarbeitest es mit Photoshop und denkst, ok, jetzt Photoshop war ja ganz cool, um folgende Sachen zu machen. Jetzt will ich aber auch mit dem anderen Programm noch ein bisschen mit dem Finger rüber pinseln. Und dann geht das halt nicht, weil alles irgendwie so...
Da willst du einen Mac haben. Deswegen will man einen Mac haben. Das ist halt für Leute, die mehr als ein Programm für eine bestimmte Information benutzen. Ich denke, das ist auch wirklich der entscheidende Unterschied derzeit zwischen dieser ganzen i-Welt und der Mac-Welt. Mac ist so universal, alles mit allem kombinieren. N mal N, genau. Und iOS ist mehr so 1 zu N. In diesem Sinne, machen wir jetzt hier den Deckel drauf.
Bevor uns hier noch was einfällt auf der letzten Minute.
Das ist ja wie wenn du Bahn fährst, wo der ICE kurz am Bahnhof immer noch mal Speed gibt, um noch in den letzten zwei Minuten einzuholen. In diesem Sinne, wir kommen wieder und wir hoffen, es hat euch ein bisschen gefallen, hier uns zuzuhören. Ich hoffe, wir haben nichts Wichtiges vergessen.